I WE ARE. OPERATING AS A SUB
COMMITTEE RIGHT NOW BUT IF YOU
LIKE TO GO AHEAD AND PRESENTWE
WILL BE GLAD TO HEAR YOUR. BILL
AB 27-29 THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM CHAIR AND A. MEMBER.
.
I'M PRESENTING THIS BILL AB
TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY NINE AS
CHAIR OF THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE
AUDIT COMMITTEE.
WHERE AN ISSUE WAS RAISED?
?
AND BY THE LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL
ARE REGARDING THE CURRENT
STATUTORY.
LANGUAGE AUTHORIZING V. LOCAL
HIGH RISK AUDIT PROGRAM.
KNELT BEFORE GOING FURTHER LET
ME FIRST MAKE IT ABSOLUTE CLEAR
THAT.
I'M FULLY IN SUPPORT OF THE
LOCAL HIGH RISK AUDIT PROGRAM.
AND I'M A FULLY IN SUPPORT OF
OUR STATE AUDITOR'S WORK ON THE
LOCAL HIGH RISK ON A PROGRAM.
BUT WE WANNA MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE.
THE RIGHT PROCEDURE IN PLACE.
SO THAT WHETHER IT'S THE CURRENT
AUDITOR OR WHETHER IT'S A
FEATURE AUDITOR.
WE HAVE.
THE.
PROPER IN MY OPINION
INSTITUTIONAL CHECKS.
ARE ON THE STATE AUDIT PROCESS.
THE ISSUE WAS RAISED BY THE
LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL'S OPINION
WHICH. IS REFERRED TO IN YOUR
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS.
BUT BASICALLY. THE CURRENT
STATUTORY LANGUAGE IS THE PLAIN
LANGUAGE IS PRETTY CLEAR.
THE STATE AUDITOR IS LIMITED.
TWO.
WHAT IT'S PUBLICLY AVAILABLE AS
WELL AS?
AUDIT INVESTIGATIVE REPORTS.
AND INFORMATION THAT THEY CAN
GET FROM THE ATTORNEY GENERAL OR
THE EAST OR THE.
THE STATE COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE.
SO WHAT.
THE STATE AUDITOR IS CURRENTLY.
CONDUCTING AND.
WHAT THEY CALL THEIR INITIAL
ASSESSMENT PROCESS?
AND APPRECIATE DE HOW YOUR
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCES SUMMARIZES.
THERE IS A FIVE STEP PROCESS
THAT THEY TAKE BEFORE THEY COME
TO THE J. LACK COMMITTEE. WITH
THE AUDIT REQUEST.
THOSE FIVE STEPS ACCORDING TO
THE PLAIN LANGUAGE OF THE
CURRENT PA CODE SECTION.
IT'S NOT AUTHORIZED AND SO
WE'RE TRYING TO CORRECT THAT
PROBLEM HERE.
.
WHAT WE'RE PROPOSING?
IS WHAT I WOULD ANALOGIZE TO.
MY PREVIOUS WORK AS A
PROSECUTOR WHERE.
YOU KNOW WHEN A LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCY THAT WANTS TO CONDUCT A
SEARCH YOU KNOW THAT THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY CHECK JUST
CAN'T GO OUT AND AND CONDUCT THE
SEARCH THEY HAVE TO GO TO THE
COURT TO GET.
TO SHOW PROBABLE CAUSE.
TO GET A SEARCH WARRANT.
AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE PROPOSING
HERE THAT YOU KNOW IT'S IT'S NOT
A FULL BLOWN.
AUDIT REQUEST BUT IT'S A.
.
IT'S A REQUEST TO THE J. LACK
COMMITTEE.
.
FOR AUTHORIZATION TO CONDUCT
THE INITIAL ASSESSMENT.
BOB THIS ALSO EMPOWERS THE STATE
AUDITOR TO NOT HAVE TO COME BACK
TO THE CHAIR ELECT COMMITTEE FOR
THE AUTHORIZATION FOR THE AUDIT.
BUT THEY MAY PROCEED AFTER THEY
J. LIKE COMMITTEE.
APPROVED THAT INITIAL
ASSESSMENT.
AND THE FOLLOWING AUDIT AS WELL
THOSE AS WELL AS ANY FOLLOW UP
AUDIT WORK GOTTA. DIE AFTER THE
COMPLETION OF THE AUDIT.
IT ALSO EMPOWERS THE AUDITOR TO
TERMINATE THE AUDIT.
IF THEY FEEL THAT THERE IS
INSUFFICIENT EVIDENCE.
TO PROCEED.
SO.
.
I BELIEVE THIS IS A.
A REASONABLE PROCEDURAL.
.
MEASURE THAT.
WILL STRENGTHEN THE AUDITOR.
TO CONDUCT THE GREAT WORK THAT
TACK SHE DOES FOR OF THE
LEGISLATURE IN.
CONDUCTING OUR LEGISLATIVE
HUNDREDS
NOT BE HAPPY TO ANSWER THE
QUESTION I I ALSO A.
HAVE.
.
LISA GOLD KILL THE PRINCIPAL
DEPUTY FROM THE ALLIES HAD OF
COUNSEL'S OFFICE WHO.
I DRAFTED THE.
OPINION UPON WHICH TO.
WE WE BASIS STATURE.
ARE ANY MEMBER HAS ANY QUESTIONS
TRY TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
BUT WE DON'T ACTUALLY SUPPORT
ANY OF THE MEASURES BUT WE'RE
HERE TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
ABOUT THE OPINION. AND TO
INDICATE TO CONFIRM THAT THERE
IS NO EXISTING STATUTORY
AUTHORITY TO DO INITIAL.
INVESTIGATIONS AT THE OCAL
AGENCY UNDER THE EXISTING
STATUTORY SCHEME.
OKAY.
*.
SO THIS IS THIS IS OUR PROFIT A
LOT OF A LOT OF CONVERSATIONS.
AND SO. AND THAT AND AND I AND
I AGREE AND THAT PROVED THAT
AUTHORITY OF THE OF THE
LEGISLATURE. AND.
IN THE PLEDGE THAT COUNCIL
FOUND THAT.
THE CURRENT WAY IN WHICH SHE WAS
OPERATING WAS THAT.
NOT NOT COVERED.
MSTER THIS ATTEMPT TO DO THAT
AND I WILL I WILL ALSO SAY AND
I'VE AND I TALKED A BIT ABOUT
THIS I KNOW MR LARA IS WORKING
ON A BILL AT THE SAME TIME.
AND HE HAD ONE OF THE BILLS
THAT STARTED THEM THE HIGH RISK
POOL SO.
WHO ARE BROKEN NATION IS FOR
AND I TODAY ABOUT WERE
SUPPORTIVE OF OF US ALL GETTING
OUR ARMS AROUND THE THE PROPER
WAY TO BE ABLE TO DO THIS WITH
THE CHECKS AND BALANCES?
OPERATING UNDER THE OVERSIGHT OF
THE OF THE LEGISLATURE BUT WITH
ALSO THAT. OF THE FREEDOM TO BE
ABLE TO DO A LOT OF SUTTER
IMPORT TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
SO.
.
IT WAS YOU CAN OPPOSITION TODAY.
CHAIR MEMBERS OF COMMITTEE
DILLON GIVENS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION
WE'RE NOT OFFICIALLY OPPOSED TO
THIS TIME BUT WE HAVE
SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS.
WITH THE LEGISLATION.
AT. THE WAY THAT THE HIGH RISK.
A LOCAL AGENCY OUT A PROGRAM WAS
PUT TOGETHER.
WHAT'S IN CONCERT WITH THE
SPECIAL DISTRICTS
LEAGUE OF CITIES SEE SACK AYE WE
WORKED WITH.
SENATOR LARA WITH THE AUDITOR'S
OFFICE TO
TO DEVELOP A PROGRAM.
THAT WAS WORKABLE AND WE
BELIEVE THAT THE WAY THAT THE
PROGRAM IS WORKING NOW. IS JUST
THAT.
THAT THE ASSESSMENTS ALLOW THE
AUDITOR TO COME IN A PRIOR TO
ELEVATING.
THE ISSUE PUBLICLY TO TO BRING
GREATER CONCERN A GREATER AND I
WOULD ARGUE UNNECESSARY CONCERN
TO HIGHLIGHT.
WHAT MAY BE HAPPENING IN A CITY
OR A SPECIAL DISTRICT I THINK
THAT'S EVIDENT BY THE WAY THE
PROGRAM'S BEEN WORKING SO FAR?
THE WAY THAT IT'S HAPPENED SO
FOR THE.
.
THE AUDITOR HAS LISTED SIX
CITIES.
TO BE.
OF THAT THAT IDENTIFIED AS HIGH
RISK TO DO MISSUS AND I DO
ASSESSMENT AND FOR SPECIAL
DISTRICTS THREE.
AFTER DOING THE INITIAL
ASSESSMENT FATHER DETERMINE THAT
THEY ONLY NEEDED TO DO THREE
AUDITS OF THE CITIES OF THREE
AFTER THE ASSESSMENT DIDN'T
REQUIRE AN AUDIT. AND FOR THE
SPECIAL DISTRICTS NONE OF THEM
REQUIRE THE AUDIT AND SO THAT IS
EVIDENT THAT THAT THAT THE
SYSTEM IS WORKING AND IT WASN'T.
.
I DON'T SEE WHY WASTING TIME
BECAUSE THESE THESE ARE VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUES.
AND IDENTIFYING YOU KNOW WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN THESE LOCAL
AGENCIES IN DETERMINE THEIR
THEIR FINANCIAL RISK.
.
WITH REGARD TO.
I APPRECIATE THE THE AUTHOR IS
TRYING TO ASSIST IN MAKING SURE
THAT THAT THE PROGRAM IS IS
MEETING THE LETTER OF THE LAW.
BUT WE WOULD ARGUE THAT THAT
RATHER THEN.
CHANGING THE PROGRAM TO MEET
THE EXISTING LA THAT WE WOULD
CHANGE THE LA TO MEET THE WAY
THAT THE THE FUNCTIONING PROGRAM
IS WORKING. AND SO ALONG THOSE
LINES WE PLAN ON SUPPORTING THE
LARA BILL.
AND THERE WAS A COMMENT MADE
WITH REGARD TO AT THE ANALOGY TO
THE SEARCH WARRANT. AND WHILE I
APPRECIATE IT THE I THINK THE
DIFFERENCE IS FOR PUBLIC
AGENCIES IS THIS IS ALL PUBLICLY
AVAILABLE INFORMATION THERE IS
NO. REQUIREMENT TO.
ROUTE SEEK YOU KNOW THAT
PERMISSION TO ASK FOR THIS
INFORMATION THE PUBLIC CAN THIS.
OVER THE PHONE ASK FOR THIS
INFORMATION.
BUT SO I DON'T BELIEVE THAT THAT
THAT THAT IS A NECESSARY CHECK
AND I THINK THAT WOULD THE WAY
THAT THIS IS BEING PROPOSED TO
BE DONE. IF THE AUDITOR WERE TO
COME TO V. J. LIKE COMMITTEE TO
ASK MAY I DO AN ASSESSMENT.
FOLLOWED BY AN AYE AYE THE
JAILER COMMITTEE. I WOULD ASSUME
WOULD BE FORCED TO APPROVE ALL
OF THEM.
AND SAY YES.
YEAH WE WE DON'T OBJECT TO YOU
DOING AN ASSESSMENT.
AND AND I DON'T THINK THAT
THAT'S A BAD THING I DON'T THINK
THAT WE WE APPRECIATE THE WAY
THAT THE PROGRAM IS IN THAT.
WHEN THE AUDITOR DETERMINES
AFTER AN ASSESSMENT THAT THEY
WANT TO DO AN AUDIT THAT THEY
COME TO THE JAIL AT COMMITTEE.
AND THE PUBLIC AGENCY HAS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO GO BEFORE THAT
COMMITTEE AND AND MAKE THEIR
CASE SAY WHAT THEY'RE DOING WHAT
WIRED SOME OF HIS USE ISSUES
OCCURRING.
HOWEVER PRIOR TO.
THERE BEING IN AN ACTUAL.
NECESSARY AUDIT IS DETERMINED
BY THE AUDITOR.
IT WOULD BE PREMATURE FOR THEM
TO COME UP AND SAY WELL. I WE
KNOW THAT YOU'VE READ THESE
ARTICLES IN THE NEWSPAPER AND
YOU'VE YOU'VE SEEN SOME OF THIS
INFORMATION.
AND NOW WE'RE TRYING TO DEFEND
OURSELVES PUBLICLY. WHAT THE
WITH THE WAY THE PROGRAM IS SET
UP NOW IS IT ENSURES DE HELPS TO
ENSURE? THE PUBLIC'S TRUST IN
GOVERNMENT AND I BELIEVE THAT.
BRINGING THE AUDIT TO THE AUDIT
REQUESTS TO THE GILLETTE
COMMITTEE PRIOR TO.
THIS INITIAL ASSESSMENT MAY.
.
WHO MADE?
HARM THE PUBLIC'S TRUST IN THEIR
GOVERNMENTS IN THAT AND THAT'S
WHY WE THE PROGRAM IS SET UP THE
WAY IT WAS. AND FOR THOSE
REASONS WE HAVE SOME SIGNIFICANT
CONCERNS AND SHOULD THIS BILL
BEFORE WE WILL BE.
WE WILL LIKELY BE TAKING IT AND
OPPOSE POSITION BUT.
FOR NOW SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS
AND WE PLANNED TO SUPPORT THE
FEDERAL ARE BILL THE ALTERNATIVE
AND I'D BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS.
THE AYE BY BE THE ARGUMENT YOU
BET I I HAVE CERTAINLY HEARD
FROM THE AUDITOR'S WELL. I'M SO
I THINK YOU FOR PER REITERATING
THE POSITION OF THE AUDITOR'S
OFFICE BOB I THINK. WE'LL LET ME
LET ME GO AHEAD.
.
I DID THE LOOKED AGAIN THE
LEGISLATURE AUTHORIZED AND I CAN
TELL YOU AS SOMEBODY WHO WAS
HEAD ON UP CITY COUNCIL WHEN THE
AUDITOR CAME AROUND.
I WOULD LIKE THE STATE
LEGISLATURE TO A WAITING ON THAT
FIRST.
BECAUSE THERE WAS A BIT WAS WE
WERE IN THE MIDST OF.
HELP.
AND THEN WE HAD TO TAKE A BREAK.
PERSON THINGS TO GO GO FORWARD
FIRST.
.
SO I. IN AM MISTER MERCER
GENERAL AIDID AT THE MINIMUM.
COURSE YOU GONNA BE ABLE TO
RESPOND UP IS GOING TO SAY I
MEAN I THINK THESE ARE GOOD YOU
YOU COULD MAKE A MISTAKE. I
THINK THESE ARE GOOD HEALTHY
CONVERSATIONS TO HAVE AND I
THINK ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
IT'S DONE IS REALLY ALLOW US TO
STEP BACK AND SAY.
HOW HOW IS IT FUNCTIONING HOW IS
IT GOING FORWARD IS IT WORKING
IS A NOT WORKING IS IT PROPERTY
WITHIN THE LAW THE LAW IS IT
OPERATING UNDER THE CA AGAIN?
THIS IS A LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEE.
THIS IS THE THE AUDITOR
OPERATES UNDER OUR AUTHORITY SO
IT ONLY MAKES SENSE THAT WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE DOING
IT IN THE WAY THAT IS MOST
HELPFUL. THAT WE STAY A ABREAST
OF WHAT IS GOING ON.
AND SO AND I MISTER MURSHID GMS
OR WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
TOGETHER TO BE ABLE TO FIND
TUNIS MR RESEARCHING YES I AGAIN
I WANT TO. EMPHASIZE THAT I'M
FULLY IN SUPPORT OF THE LOCAL
HIGH RISK AUDIT PROGRAM AND I I
BELIEVE THAT THE REP CENTER FOR
THE SPECIAL DISTRICTS. IS
INDICATING HOW OUR CURRENT STATE
AUDITOR IS EXERCISING HER POWER
RESPONSIBLY AS SHOWN BY.
HOW?
THAT SHE HAS TERMINATED HER
LOCAL HIGH RISK.
ENQUIRIES AFTER THE INITIAL
ASSESSMENT BUT I I DO WANT TO
EMPHASIZE THAT I I I DO.
I BELIEVE THAT THE SPECIAL
DISTRICTS IS WRONG IN TERMS OF.
THE INITIAL ASSESSMENT JUST
BEING LIMITED TO TO PUBLICLY
AVAILABLE INFORMATION.
BECAUSE THAT IT OF THE THE FIVE
STEP PROCESS IS.
ARE SUMMARIZED IN YOUR COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS AND IT'S ALSO ON THE
STATE AUDITOR'S PAGE.
THAT THE FIVE STEP PROCESS THAT
THE STATE AUDITOR ENGAGES
PRIOR TO JAIL LACK APPROVAL. IS
FIRST.
LOOKING TO AVAILABLE
INFORMATION.
FROM A LOCAL PUBLIC AGENCY
THAT'S PUBLICLY AVAILABLE
INFORMATION.
BUT THEN PROCEEDING TO
INITIAL CONCERNS.
MEETING WITH AS MANAGEMENT TO
DISCUSS RISK FACTORS AND
EXPECTED TIME LINES FOR THE
AUDITOR'S ANALYSIS.
VISITING THE AGENCY PERFORMING
AN INITIAL ASSESSMENT WHICH THE
AUDIT TEAM SPENDS APPROXIMATELY
TWO TO THREE WEEKS ON SITE. AND
THEN HOLDING AN INITIAL
ASSESSMENT CLOSE OUT MEETING
WITH AGENCY MANAGEMENT AT THIS
ALL HAPPENS BEFORE J. LACK
APPROVAL HERE SO. I THINK EACH
AND EVERY MEMBER OF THIS
COMMITTEE WOULD APPRECIATE. YOU
KNOW THAT KNOWLEDGE AT LEAST A
HEADS UP THAT.
THAT THE STATE AUDITOR IS
CONDUCTING ALL OF THIS IN YOUR
DISTRICT BEFORE THEY COME FOUR
CHAIR LIKE APPROVAL AND THAT IS
THE POINT OF MY BILL.
I THINK SHE WE CAN ESTABLISH A
QUORUM SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
BUT A MONTH IS EGGMAN HERE THAN
A MONTH IS EGGMAN PRESIDENT
PATTERSON.
PATTERSON PRESIDENT BURKE.
FRAZIER. FRAZIER PRESIDENT
MEDINA. MEDINA PRESIDENT LACKEY.
LACKEY PRESIDENT QUIRK SILVA.
SILVA PRESIDENT.
THANK YOU WE HAVE A CORE.
.
YEAH I THINK THIS IS A I MEAN I
THINK IT'S FASCINATING THAT
THAT'S AND THIS IS COMING
FORWARD I THINK THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE ALL WANT TO
ROLL UP OUR SLEEVES AND AND
CONTINUE. TO HAVE THESE
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT.
WE WILL HAVE BUT YOU DO NOT
RESPECT AUDITOR AND AND THE ON
THE UNDER OFFICE BUT THIS IT'S A
IS IT POSITION IS NOT ALWAYS
GONNA BE THE SAME PERSON TO WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT. THE WILL FEEL
REALLY COMFORTABLE WITH THE WAY
IT'S GOING AT THERE'S
TRANSPARENCY.
AND TRANSPARENCY COMES FROM
FROM KNOWLEDGE AND AND KNOWLEDGE
COMES FROM PEOPLE COMING BEFORE
COMMITTEE IN BEING ABLE TO SAY
WE HAVE CONSEQUENCE EARNS ABOUT
THIS THIS AND THIS AND SO WE
WANT TO BE ABLE TO GO FORWARD.
BOMB SO.
IT QUESTIONS THE QUESTIONS
BECAUSE IN THE COMMITTEE.
MISS QUIRK SILVA.
.
I APOLOGIZE CAME IN A LITTLE BIT
AFTER YOUR TESTIMONY BUT UP. AS
FAR AS IT LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND
WHETHER IT BE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COUNTY SPECIAL DISTRICT I EVEN
SCHOOL BOARDS ALL OF THE ELECTED
POSITIONS THAT WE HAVE. ON IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT I HAVE FOUND
WITH CONSTITUENTS OVER AND OVER
IS THEY HAVE VERY VERY LITTLE
KNOWLEDGE.
OF WHAT THE PROCESSES ARE NOT
ONLY FOR VERYBASIC THINGS LIKE
HOW YOU VOTE BROWN ACT ALL OF
THESE OTHER THINGS BUT WHEN IT
COMES TO ISSUES. THAT THERE'S
CONCERN OVER.
THEN WHEN YOU MOVE TO THE NEXT.
STEP MAYBE TO THE STATE ON AN
AUDIT.
I CAN GUARANTEE THAT ALL VERY
FEW PEOPLE EVEN UNDERSTAND WHAT
THAT IS SO IT'S NOT ONLY THE
WORK OF THE AUDITOR BUT IT'S
ALSO THE INFORMATION THAT IS
BROUGHT BACK TO OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES. TO OUR COUNTIES AND
THAT REALLY IS WHAT I APPRECIATE
ABOUT THIS COMMITTEE BECAUSE.
IT'S ONE THING FOR PEOPLE THAT
ARE IN HOUSE SO MANY THE PEOPLE
ARE IN THE AUDIENCE HERE MANY OF
THE PEOPLE HERE WE COME TO SPEAK
THE SAME LANGUAGE A IN MANY WAYS
BUT WHEN YOU GO OUT TO THE
AVERAGE CONSTITUENT YOU WHICH IS
WHO WE SERVE. THEY NEED TO
UNDERSTAND AND HAVE FAITH THAT
UP. AND CONFIDENCE IN THE
PROCESSES WE TAKE AND UP MANY
TIMES THERE'S COMPLAINT AND THEY
HAVE NO IDEA WHO TO GO TO. AND
SO THEIR FIRST STEP IS PROBABLY
LOCAL GOVERNMENT BUT ONCE YOU
START TO DRILL DOWN.
THAT THEY DON'T ALWAYS AGREE ON
WHAT THE RESULT IS THAT THEY
WANT BUT THEY DO WANT
TRANSPARENCY THEY DO WANT
ACCOUNTABILITY AND I THINK ON
THE REPUBLICAN DEMOCRAT SIDE. WE
CAN AGREE ON THAT THOSE TWO
WORDS I DON'T THINK THERE'S MUCH
DISAGREEMENT SO I SUPPORT THIS
BECAUSE TO ME. AS MUCH PROCESSES
WE CAN DO TO MAKE SURE OUR
PUBLIC HAS CONFIDENCE IS
SOMETHING THAT I SUPPORT BY
THANK YOU FOR THIS BILL.
IT'S FRAZIER.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND.
.
I DO SEE.
A COLLABORATION IN YOUR FUTURE
MISTER MAYOR SEARCHING.
OF WITH THE.
.
GOOD WILL OF OUR CHAIR OF MAKING
SURE THAT IT DOES GET THROUGH
WITH HER APPROVAL.
AND I DO LOOK FORWARD TO
DISCUSSING THE MERITS OF WHAT
THE SPECIAL DISTRICTS ARE
TALKING ABOUT.
ALL HAVE TO SAY THAT MY
EXPERIENCES WITH WITH THE STATE
AUDITOR THROUGH THE DELTA CAUCUS
HAS BEEN.
STREAMLINED ARE PRODUCTIVE IN AN
OF VALUE AND AS THE CHERISHED
MENTIONED.
WE ALL HIGHLY.
.
APPRECIATE THE WORK OF THE STATE
AUDITOR. HOW ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT I WILL NOTE THAT YOU MIGHT
ALSO RECOGNIZE GOING FORWARD IS?
WHEN THE STATE AUDITOR IS
ENGAGED IN DOES THEIR. THEIR
INVESTIGATION OR HER REPORT.
THAT IT COMES OUT THAT THERE ARE
SOME GLARING ISSUES.
FROM STATE AGENCIES.
THERE'S NOTHING THAT WE CAN DO
BASICALLY TO.
STOP WHAT THEY'RE DOING.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL DEFENSE
STATE AGENCIES.
DOESN'T PROSECUTE.
WE HAVE JUST THE ABILITY TO
DEFUND HAS AS A FUNDING. BODY.
OR MAKE NEW LAWS.
BUT THE PEOPLE THAT ARE BOUND TO
BE.
CULPABLE IN IN WRONGDOINGS.
THERE'S NEVER ACCOUNTABILITY TO
TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE.
DON'T DO IT AGAIN.
COULDN'T CASE IN POINT WAS THE.
.
STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL AND THE
STATE WATER BOARD AN EX PARTE
COMMUNICATIONS THAT WERE CLEARLY
FOUND BY THE STATE AUDITOR.
NOTHING HAPPENED THERE IS
NOTHING THAT. I MEAN JUST WAS
IDENTIFIED SO IF THERE WAS
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN PUT IN
PLACE.
IN.
IN STATUE WERE.
THE AGENCIES WERE RESPONSIBLE
INDIVIDUALS WERE RESPONSIBLE.
GOING FOR A FACT THAT WOULD BE
VERY HELPFUL I THINK THIS
COMMITTEE. HAS THE CHAIR.
COULD ACTUALLY SO SPEARHEAD THIS
WITH YOU AS JAIL ACT.
TO MAKE SURE THAT.
THAT WHEN WHEN THINGS ARE FOUND
OUT TO BE.
WRONG DOINGS OF THE PUBLIC SEES
THAT WE ACTUALLY ACT UPON THEM.
AND THAT'S BEEN MY FRUSTRATION
WHEN WE SEE THESE THINGS HAPPEN
SO. LOOKING FORWARD TO YOU KNOW
GOING FORWARD.
AND AND AND ENGAGE YOU WANT I
CAN ALSO BUT I THINK THIS THIS
COMMITTEE IS ABSOLUTELY
ESSENTIAL MEN TURN. IN
FURTHERING THE PROCESS.
OF FILE AFTER THEY DO THEIR GOOD
WORK AND HOW WE CAN MAKE THEM
ACCOUNTABLE.
I AGREE I WOULD I'VE I'VE TALKED
WITH THAT AND SPEAKER AND IN A
PEOPLE ABOUT TRYING TO MAKE THIS
COMMITTEE MORE SOME LIKE THE
CONGRESSIONAL OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEE WHERE PEOPLE HAVE TO
COME BACK AND WE HEAR MUCH MORE
ABOUT IT.
BUT SO YEAH I DO BELIEVE THAT
AGAIN TRANSPARENCY PUBLIC
AWARENESS ALL OF THOSE THINGS AS
WE WANT THE PUBLIC TO BE ABLE TO
TRUST THE WORK OF THE GOVERNMENT
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE. THAT WE
ARE IS FULLY TRANSPARENT WITH
ACCOUNTABILITY AS WE CAN
POSSIBLY BE.
PATTERSON.
I JUST BRIEFLY I I THINK THE OF.
LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL WHO ARE
OBVIOUSLY IS RAISED SOME.
IMPORTANT AREAS HERE.
OF FOR THE TIME BEING.
I THINK I'M I'M GONNA LAY OFF
AND AND ENCOURAGE.
THE A COLLABORATION.
WITH.
THE SENATE AND BRINGING A
SIMILAR BILL.
AND THEN KIND OF SEE HOW HOW
ALL THAT PULLS TOGETHER AND.
SO I'LL BE LAYING OFF BUT I
WANT TO CONTINUE TO.
AND ENGAGE IN THE EFFORT HERE
TO.
TO GET THIS TO GET THIS RIGHT SO
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
RIOS.
RIGHT WITH EVERY EMOTION.
THE TRIP WAS COLOR.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND REAR
FOR TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS THAT MONTH THAT
SEGMENT SETTLEMENT THIS SEGMENT
AYE PATTERSON.
PATTERSON NOT VOTING BURKE.
FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE LACKEY. LACKEY NO
MEDINA. MEDINA AYE COOK SELLO.
SILVA AYE.
THAT BUILDS UP LIKE YOU WE
APPRECIATE. HEARING A LOT MORE
ABOUT THIS.
WORK WILL CONTINUE AS WE LIKE TO
HEAR.
OF IF WOULD THERE BE A MOTION TO
APPROVE THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
ALL RIGHT NOW ON THE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR WE HAVE A
MISTER KING'S TWENTY FOUR
SEVENTY FIVE.
A AND THE MISTER FRASIER'S.
TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY FOUR MISTER
ONCE TWENTY SEVEN NINETY MISTER
SALSAS THIRTY ONE SEVENTY NINE.
AND MISS IRWIN'S THIRTY TO FIFTY
ONE.
SENATOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS WITH
RECOMMENDATION TO CONSENT.
THAT MONTH THIS EGGMAN THAT
MONTH EGGMAN AYE.
PATTERSON PATTERSON AYE BURKE.
FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE LACKEY. LACKEY AYE
MEDINA. MEDINA AYE QUIRK SILVA.
KURTZ SELA I.
ALRIGHT.
CONSENT CALENDAR PASSES AND I
SEE MR BIGELOW SITTING IN THE.
PRESENTING TODAY TWENTY THREE
NINETY SIX.
REFERRING TO AG DISTRICTS.
THANK. SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
REPLACE YOUR IS TO BE HERE
TODAY.
TODAY I HAVE A ST FORD BILL I'M
HERE TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY THREE NINETY SIX
REGARDING FAIRS. THIS MAJOR
REQUESTED IS REQUESTED BY THE
CDF A AND IT WILL CAN HELP
CLARIFY THE LAW. EMPLOYEES CAN
LEGALLY WORK AT MULTIPLE FAIRS
AS YOU KNOW FAIRS HAVE LIMITED
RESOURCES AND AB TWENTY THREE
NINETY SIX WILL ENSURE THAT THEY
ARE ABLE TO USE THEM WISELY.
PLEA.
BOY AM I HAVING A TONGUE
TWISTING DAY. I CAN GUARANTEE.
ANYWAY TODAY WITH ME IS LOUIS
BROWN.
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT
YOU MAY HAVE AS A COMMITTEE.
OKAY
MISS ROSE EXPECTS PORT. MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
LOUIS BROWN ON BEHALF WESTERN
FAIRS ASSOCIATION.
WHEN THE FUNDING WAS CUT FOR
DISTRICT AG ASSOCIATIONS AND
THEY BECAME VERY ENTREPRENEURIAL
SPECIALLY THE SMALL TO MIDSIZE
FAIRS HOW WHO COULD NOT REALLY
BUDGET TO HAVE FULL TIME STAFF.
WE START TO SEE THAT THE
EXPERTISE WOULD BE SHARED
AMONGST DIFFERENT ACT DISTRICT
AG ASSOCIATIONS. EVEN SOME THE
LARGER DISTRICT AG ASSOCIATIONS
WOULD LOAN STAFF TO THE SMALL TO
MEDIUM SIZE FAIRS JUST TO HELP
THEM CONTINUE WITH THEIR
ACTIVITIES. LO AND BEHOLD WE
FOUND THAT THIS IS NOT PERMITTED
BY THE LAW.
AND SO WE'RE HERE TODAY TO ASK
FOR THIS CLARIFICATION TO BE
MADE SO THAT THIS TYPE OF
ACTIVITY CAN CONTINUE.
WHILE WE ARE STARTING TO
RECEIVE SOME FUNDING FROM THE
STATE STILL NOT THE SAME LEVEL
THAT WE ONCE RECEIVED IN IT AND
THIS EMPLOYEE SHARING. A WITH
APPROVAL BY THE BOARD AYE STONE
IMPORTANT A COMPONENT FOR MANY
OF THESE FAIRS IN THE STATE'S WE
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
YOU VERY MUCH ANYBODY ELSE
BECAUSE SUPPORT TODAY HEY WHAT
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS FINE BILL.
I THOUGHT NOT OKAY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
THE BILL SECOND.
THANK YOU MUCH I APPRECIATE
YOUR ONGOING WORK ON THIS MISTER
BIGELOW AND AND NOT MISTER
BROWN.
.
DON'T CHERUB ECHOES OF WE TRY TO
DO A LOT AROUND FAIRS AND THEY
CONTINUE TO STRUGGLE AND AND AND
I THINK WE CONTINUE TO HAVE TO
CONTINUE TO FIGHT FOR THEM.
WHICH HAD A BIG ASPARAGUS VESTED
OUR FAIRGROUNDS US TIME AND
THEY'RE DOING WHATEVER THEY
CAN'T HAVE MORE ACTIVITIES ON.
ON THE FAIRGROUNDS SO.
SECRETARY ADMISSIBLE WHICH I
CLOSE I WAS JUST GONNA SAY AYE
AS WE ALL PROBABLY KNOW WE LOVE
OUR FAIRS.
AND DOWN THE STATE AND THERE'S
HAVE TO SHARE SUPPLIES PANELS.
PLATFORMS FOR PRESENTATION.
LOW BEHOLD WE FIND OUT THAT THE
EMPLOYEES ARE ABLE TO
NECESSARILY HELP SHUTTLE THAT
BACK AND FORTH SO THIS WILL BE A
RESOLUTION TO THIS ISSUE WE
ENCOURAGE AN AYE VOTE.
THAT'S RIGHT NOT DOWN BARRIERS
AND HELP PEOPLE WORK SMARTER NOT
HARDER OKAY SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS THAT AMONG THE
SEGMENT BY SOME OF THIS EGGMAN
AYE PATTERSON. PATTERSON AYE
BURKE.
FRAZIER FRAZIER AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE MEDINA MEDINA AYE
QUIRK SILVA.
KIRK SILVA AYE.
BUILDING UP THANK YOU MEMBERS.
STRONG
.
A MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS IS MY
PLEASURE TO PRESENT TO YOU AB
TWENTY SIX SEVENTY ONE. A BILL
THAT SEEKS TO PROVIDE
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
IN THE REGULATORY PROCESS.
I SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL WILL
REQUIRE MAJOR REGULATIONS WITH
AN ESTIMATED ECONOMIC IMPACT.
FIFTY MILLION OR MORE.
TO
RETURN TO LEGISLATIVE REVIEW AND
APPROVAL IF THE LEGISLATURE DOES
NOT ACT ON THE SUBMITTED
REGULATION. IT WILL GO INTO
EFFECT ACCORDING TO THE CURRENT
RULE MAKING SCHEDULE.
THIS BILL ALSO TASK REDWOOD TOO
AGENCIES TO REVIEW EXISTING
REGULATIONS AND IDENTIFY ANY
REGULATIONS THAT ARE. THAT ARE
DUPLICATIVE OVERLAPPING
INCONSISTENT OR OUT OF DATE.
AND TASK AGENCIES TO ADOPT
AMENDMENTS TO ACHIEVE THESE
OBJECTIVES.
THERE ARE OVER TWO HUNDRED STATE
AGENCIES WITH THE AUTHORITY TO
ISSUE REGULATIONS AFFECTING
EVERY INDUSTRY STATEWIDE.
THE COST OF THESE REGULATIONS
NOT ONLY IMPACT SMALL BUSINESSES
BUT THEY ALSO AFFECTED FAMILIES
AND INDIVIDUALS.
LOW INCOME FAMILIES IN
PARTICULAR OFTEN BEAR THE BURDEN
TO HIGHER COSTS AND ESSENTIAL
GOODS AND SERVICES.
AS LEGISLATORS COOPER WE PROVIDE
ADEQUATE OVERSIGHT OVER BY THE
TRADE BODIES WS EXPECT TO
PROPERLY IMPLEMENT THE LAWS WE
PASS.
IT'S UP TO US TO KEEP OUR
ELECTED BUREAUCRATS ACCOUNTABLE.
THIS BILL IS A COMMON SENSE
MEASURE THAT WILL BRING NEEDED
CHECKS AND BALANCES SO WE AS
ELECTED OFFICIALS. CAN MORE
EFFECTIVELY REVIEW THESE
REGULATIONS AND ENSURE THAT
THERE ARE APPROPRIATE THAT THEY
ARE APPROPRIATE GIVEN THE
CURRENT ECONOMIC ENVIRONMENT AND
CONSISTENT WITH THE INTENT OF
THE LEGISLATURE. WITH ME TO
DISCUSS THE MERITS OF AB TWENTY
SIX ANYONE ISRAEL COOK WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATE.
THANK YOU TO THE
CHAIR IN THE COMMITTEE EMINEM'S
TERRELL COOK I REPRESENT THE
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION WE'RE
HERE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY SIX SEVENTY ONE AS A GOOD
GOVERNANCE MEASURE. THAT WILL
INCREASE LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT
AND IMPROVE THE REGULATORY
SYSTEM UP AS A BIG PICTURE
FRAMEWORK UP ALL EXECUTIVE
AGENCY AUTHORITY BEGINS WITH THE
GRANT BY THE LEGISLATURE SO
UPSET AND RULES HAVE THE FORCE
OF LAW SO IT'S IMPORTANT. THAT
WHEN AGENCIES ARE DOING THE RULE
MAKING THAT THEY DO NOT.
CONTRAVENED LEGISLATIVE INTENT.
.
AB TICKS AB TWENTY SIX SEVENTY
ONE BEGINS TO ADDRESS THAT
PROBLEM UP BY CREATING A
MECHANISM FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO
MAKE IT INCREASED ITS
RESPONSIBILITY IN OVERSIGHT OF
THESE EXECUTIVE AGENCIES. WHICH
IS CONSISTENT WITH A TWENTY
SEVENTEEN REPORT BY THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE TO
ESTABLISH SUCH AN OVERSIGHT INTO
THE.
ARE CURRENTLY THE WHAT WE HAVE
IS IS IN OUR EXISTING SYSTEM IS
THE O. L. A IN THE OF REVIEWING
AGENCY RULEMAKING UNDER THE APA
BUT. A THAT REVIEW WAS A
PROCEDURAL CHECK THE OIL IS NOT
EQUIPPED TO MAKE EVALUATIONS OF
WHETHER NOT A RULE DIVERGES FROM
LEGISLATIVE INTENT ONLY THE
LEGISLATURE CAN DO THAT. ARE
CURRENTLY IF.
REGULATION.
DONE BY ANY AGENCY IS DIVERGENT
FROM A GREG LEGISLATIVE INTENT.
WHAT RESULTS IS A LENGTHY COURT
PROCESS WHICH IS UNPREDICTABLE
AT ITS LENGTH BE IT'S COSTLY AND
AT THE END WHAT WE HAVE IS THAT
THE LEGISLATURE MUST START BOTH
THE LIBERTY PROCESS ALL OVER
AGAIN TO CREATE AND?
THAT'S NOT IDEAL FOR ANYONE AND
IT DELAYED ANY POTENTIAL BENEFIT
THAT IT MIGHT HAVE.
.
ONCE THIS A MECHANISM IS IN
PLACE ULTIMATELY IT IS FLEXIBLE
WE HAVE SEEN AND IT'S UP TO THE
LEGISLATURE DETERMINE HOW ROBUST
OR EFFECTIVE THAT THEY WOULD
LIKE IT TO BE AND HOW MUCH VALUE
THEY WOULD LIKE TO ADD. A WE
SEEN IN OTHER STATES CONNECTICUT
HAS A FULL LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE
DEVOTED TO REVIEWING MAJOR
RULES.
COLORADO HAS AN OFFICE OF
LEGISLATIVE AND LEGAL SERVICES
TO REVIEW WITH BERMAN IF THEY.
CONTRAVENE LEGISLATIVE
AUTHORITY WYOMING A MAIN HAVE A
SIMILAR SORT PROCESS TO TO WHAT
WE SEE HERE.
A THE SECOND PART OF THIS BILL
ARE REQUIRED THAT AGENCIES ARE
REVIEW THE REGULATIONS DETERMINE
ANY AT DETERMINE THAT ANY BETTER
OUT OF DATE. INCONSISTENT
OVERLAPPING OR DUPLICATIVE AND
IF THEY ARE AGENCIES MUST
RECONCILE AMEND THEIR
REGULATIONS TO TO BRING THEM.
.
IN HARMONY
BUT IT'S NOT A MANDATE TO REPEAL
THAT REGULATIONS THAT ARE
WORKING MORE EFFECTIVE.
IT ENCOURAGED AGENCIES TO TALK
TO EACH OTHER TO REMOVE SILOS.
INTO PROVIDE. CERTAINTY FOR
REGULATED ENTITIES GIVING THEM A
PLACE A SINGLE PLACE TO GO TO.
AND AND CLEAR A CLEAR PATH THE
COMPLAINTS SO FOR THESE REASONS
WE ASK YOU TO VOTE ISLAND BILL
TODAY.
MAYBE SPEAK IN A POSITION TODAY.
WELL.
BEN CHAIR MEMBERS MICHAEL YOUNG
WITH THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION WE ARE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE THE BILL A WE BELIEVE
THAT THIS BILL WOULD PREFER
MOSQUITO RESOURCES FROM STATE
AGENCIES TO PERFORM.
DUPLICATIVE AND NECESSARY
REGULATORY REVIEWS.
THERE'S ALREADY A VIGOROUS
PROCESS TO MAKE SURE THEIR RATES
ARE CONSISTENT NOT DUPLICATIVE.
WIND THE STATE AGENCIES WHO ARE
CREATES THE RULE OR CREATES A
REGULATION HAS BIGGEST PROCESS
TO MAKE SURE THAT IT'S
CONSISTENT AND EFFECTIVE WITH.
CURRENT LAW OF THE AWAY YELL
BENDER EXISTING LAW HAS THE
AUTHORITY TO.
MAKE SURE THAT THOSE RULES
REGULATIONS ARE CONSISTENT AND
NOT DUPLICATIVE AND MEET THE
STANDARDS OF THE APA.
AND LASTLY THERE IS ALSO A
VIGOROUS PROCESS FOR IF SOMEHOW
REGULATION US THAT THE CRACKS IN
DOESN'T YOU IT ISN'T IDENTIFIED
THROUGH. THE PROTOCOLS AND
PROCEDURES WE CAN ASSIST THAT I
JUST DISCUSSED OF THERE IS A
PROCESS WHERE OF THE PUBLIC CAN
ASK THE AGENCY TO REPEAL A
REGULATION IS A PROCESS WHERE
THE LEGISLATURE CAN INITIATE. A
PRIORITY REVIEW TO RECRUIT
REPEAL THE REGULATION THERE ARE.
SEVERAL LAYERS OF CHECKS AND
BALANCES TO MAKE SURE THAT.
THE UNDERLYING LAW THAT THIS
ALLEGED THAT THIS BODY PASSES
AND THEY'RE REGULATION THAT'S A.
THAT'S A APPROVED A MEETS THE
STANDARDS OF THE APA IT NEEDS
THE APPROVAL OF THE LEGISLATURE
AND ALL THAT VIOS THIS BODY ALSO
HAS THE AUTHORITY TO COME BACK
AND SAY NO STATE AGENCY YOU'VE
GONE TOO FAR. WE'RE GONNA
PASSABLE DIRECTING YOU TO.
DO EXACTLY WHAT WE WANT TO DO
AND THERE'S BEEN SEVERAL
EXAMPLES OF WHERE THE STUDIES
DONE THAT WORK THEY'VE.
PASSED LEGISLATION TO
SPECIFICALLY DIRECT A AN AGENCY
TO PERFORM CERTAIN TASKS SO I
IT'S OUR VIEW THAT THE CURRENT
PROCESS IS WORKING.
AND DEAD.
THE DANGERS COMPONENT OF
DIVERTING THOSE STATE RESOURCES
TO PERFORM THIS DUPLICATIVE
REVIEW MEANS THAT STATE AGENCIES
ARE PERFORMING THEIR CORE
MISSION SO THE LABOR AGENCY
ISN'T BITING WASTE BETH CALTRANS
IS IN BUILDING ROADS.
DID DEAL JAY IS IN DEFENDING
OUR LAWS THEY HAVE TO DIVERT
RESOURCES FROM PERFORMING THEIR
CORE MISSION TO DO WHERE I
REGULATORY REGULATORY REVIEW
THAT'S ALREADY BEING DONE BY THE
AGENCY AND I WAS ALREADY
AND BY THE AWAY ILL. SO FOR
THOSE REASONS WERE OPPOSED.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
THE COMMITTEE JEREMY SMITH HERE
BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL LYFT
ASSOCIATE MYSELF WITH A PREVIOUS
BECAUSE COMMENTS IS THAT TWO
POINTS FIRST OF ALL.
THIS LEGISLATURE AND YOUR
PREDECESSORS.
HAVE AGREED THAT THERE ARE.
BUT THINGS THAT DON'T NEED TO BE
AND THEN BILLS YOU DON'T NEED TO
GET GRANULAR ON WHAT.
A A SPECIFIC LAW SHOULD LOOK
LIKE REGULATION SHOULD LOOK LIKE
YOU PASS A LAW YOU PASS A BILL.
AND YOU LEAVE IT TO AN AGENCY.
WHO CONVENE STAKEHOLDERS AN
AGENCY WHO HANDLES THAT AREA OF
LIFE AN AREA OF LAW? TO CREATE
WHAT NEEDS TO HAPPEN BASED ON
WHAT YOUR BILL SAID.
AND YOU KNOW WE SAW THIS JUST
LAST YEAR TWO YEARS AGO AT THE
HEAT ON THIS REGULATION YOU GUYS
PASSED A LAW THAT SAID. CAL OSHA
SHALL DO HE ALMOST REGULATION BY
A CERTAIN DATE YOU DIDN'T TALK
ABOUT TEMPERATURES IN TALK ABOUT
HUMIDITY YOU DIDN'T GET INTO THE
DETAILS. YOU JUST CENTER
DIRECTION AND I WOULD JUST STAY
WITH CAL OSHA FOR SECOND AND
PICK UP ON A POINT OF THE
PREVIOUS SPEAKER SAID BY SAYING.
OUR DEBATE ON THE DAY THERE'S
AROUND TWO HUNDRED CAL OSHA
INSPECTORS FOR SEVENTEEN MILLION
PEOPLE WHO WORK IN THE STATE.
THOSE INSPECTORS ARE IN THE
FIELD ARE ALSO THE ONES THAT DO
THE REGULATIONS
THEY COME OUT FROM THE FIELD TO
WORK ON REGULATIONS THAT THEY
ARE EXPERTS IN.
IF YOU HAVE TO FOLLOW THIS
PROCESS.
AND. BY THE LEGISLATURE'S INTO
LOOKING OVER THE SHOULDER THE
ENTIRE TIME THEY'RE GONNA BE
THERE NOT TO BE ABLE TO DO THEIR
JOB AS WELL THEY SHOULD AND THEN
THEY'RE NOT GONNA BE IN THE
FIELD.
ENFORCING REGULATIONS LIKE THEY
SHOULD SO FOR THOSE REASONS WERE
ALSO OPPOSED THANK YOU THINK
YOU'RE MUCH ELSE BEGIN
OPPOSITION TODAY.
A MAN CHAIR MEMBERS A COMMISSION
DOESN'T ON BEHALF OF THE
TEAMSTERS THE AMALGAMATED
TRANSIT UNION AT THE MACHINIST
UNITE HERE.
AND UTILITY WORKERS UNION ALL
POST.
MARK MCKINNEY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION ON
THAT FOR ALL THE REASONS STATED
BY ON THE OPPOSITION WE TOO ARE
ALSO OPPOSED.
OKAY. GUM SO I I I WILL SAY I
HAVE.
HAVE NO RECOMMENDATION ON THIS.
BUT I WE SEE IT IS UNNECESSARY
WE WE PASSED THE BILL'S WE WE DO
THAT LEGISLATION AGENCIES
IMPLEMENT THEM WE ALWAYS HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO BRING THEM
BACK IS IT
IT'S COMMITTEE OR TO BRING THEM
BACK OR TO DO MORE LEGISLATION.
AND WE'VE WE HAVE CERTAINLY DONE
UP MULTIPLE TIMES OF ALL SET ON
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEES WE HAVE
AGENCIES COMMAND WITH THE BEAT
NAY ARE BE ARE OR WHOM EVER.
IS THE SAME COMMENTS I MADE TO
YOU LAST YEAR WE BROUGHT THIS
BILL UP.
YOU DIDN'T. EVEN TRY TO NARROW
INTRODUCED IN WITH THE POLICY
CONCERNS IT'S SAME BILL THAT WE.
THE DID MAKE IT LAST YEAR AND
NOW IT'S BACK AGAIN THIS YEAR
SO.
IF YOU ARE SERIOUS
ABOUT WANTING TO DO MORE OF THIS
A OVERSIGHT AND I WOULD SUGGEST
YOU FIND A BETTER WAY TO TAILOR
IT DOWN TO MAKE IT MORE
FUNCTIONAL AND NOT JUST CREATE A
LOT OF BUSY WORK FOR PEOPLE. OUT
MOST AGENCIES ARE DOING THIS
KIND OF WORK.
SO.
AND A QUESTION TO COLLEGE IN THE
COMMITTEE.
BOB.
WELL I'M GONNA.
SPECULATE YEAH. HAD DISAGREE
WITH THAT WITH THE CHAIR.
.
AND WE ARE WE HAVE REGULATORY.
PROBLEMS THAT ARE DEEP AND WIDE
ACROSS ALMOST EVERY DIVISION OR
DEPARTMENT.
AB IF THE PROCESS PRESENTLY IN
PLACE WOULD WOULD WOULD BE
WORKING WE WOULD NOT HAVE. ALL
OF THE CONFUSION IN THE
DIFFICULTY THAT WE DO PRESENTLY
MY AS SITE.
JUST ONE.
.
A OUTDATED DATA SET OF
REGULATIONS ITS TITLE TWENTY TO
WITH RESPECT TO OF. HEALTH
DELIVERY AND THE LIKE
REPEATEDLY.
HOSPITALS AND CLINICS AND OTHERS
HAVE TO GO THROUGH AT A REGULAR
EFFORT TO WAVE.
NONSENSICAL RULES AND
REGULATIONS DUPLICATIVE OF VERY
EXPENSIVE.
THERE ARE WAIVER PROCESSES.
IN IT.
BUT IT IS YOU TALK ABOUT TIME
CONSUMING AND YOU TALK ABOUT
THAT THE BUREAUCRACIES HAVING TO
DO. A UNNECESSARY WORK AND NOT
BE ABLE TO DO THEIR. PRIMARY
FUNCTION.
THESE WAIVERS ARE JUST SUCH AN
EXAMPLE THEY ARE ROUTINELY
WAIVED AS IF THE REGULATIONS
DON'T EXIST WELL THE REASON FOR
THAT IS. THOSE REGULATIONS WERE
MAY BE PASSED IN THE NINETEEN
X. THESE LAST TIME THEY WERE
REFORM WAS IN THE NINETEEN.
SEVENTIES AND THE RESULT HAS
BEEN A IT FOR HOSPITALS IN MY
DISTRICT THAT.
UTTERLY UNNECESSARY.
FINES AND OTHER ACTIONS THAT
EVEN THE MEMBERS OF THE
BUREAUCRACY APOLOGIZE TO THE
HOSPITAL'S FOR HAVING.
UP TO PUT FORWARD THERE HAS TO
BE THIS KIND OF.
OVERSIGHT A.
BECAUSE OF THE OF THE PROBLEMS
THAT ARE RIGHT.
AND ARE AT.
IDENTIFIED ALMOST REGULARLY BY
MEMBERS.
WHO HAVE ANY KIND OF ENGAGEMENT
WITH CONSTITUENTS IN THE AREA
THAT THIS THIS IS I THINK
APPROPRIATE?
?
AT AN ALLY AND I THINK THAT
DEAD.
IF WE ARE SERIOUS ABOUT.
OF THE REGULATORY REFORM AND
MODERNIZATION THAT WE WOULD BE
EMBRACING EN ENGAGING.
.
TO TRY TO GET THE THESE KIND OF
VEHICLES.
IN PLACE
OR ELSE WE'RE JUST GONNA
CONTINUE TO. RUN AROUND IN
CIRCLES WITH THESE
CRAZY WAIVERS AND.
FINDS THAT ARE TIED TO
REGULATIONS THAT EVEN THE
REGULATORS DON'T THINKER
PARTICULARLY EFFECTIVE SO FOR
THOSE REASONS I. I THOUGHT I
SUPPORT THE BILL AND AND WOULD
HOPE THAT.
THAT WE CAN MOVE FORWARD
DOESN'T GIVE A GOOD IDEA FOR A
BILL NEXT YEAR MR.
ON A WAIVERS. OKAY ANYBODY ELSE
MISS QUIRK SILVA.
THANK YOU SOME A MEMBER FONG UP
FOR THIS PRESENTATION YOU KNOW
THIS IS A REALLY DIFFICULT BILL
I I KNOW THAT IN THE SCOPE OF
THIS BUILDING IT MAY NOT BE ON
ANYBODY'S RADAR. BUT AS THAT.
BUT CHAIR OF THE JOBS COMMITTEE
THIS IS DEFINITELY AN ISSUE WE
HEAR MANY MANY TIMES US OUT. A
DUPLICATIVE REGULATIONS BUT
AGAIN LOOKING AT WHETHER IT BE
SMALL OR LARGE BUSINESSES
PARTICULARLY SO I'M NOT TALKING
NECESSARILY ABOUT. A GOVERNMENT
BUT I'M TALKING ABOUT
BUSINESSES.
THEY OFTEN JUST DON'T KNOW WHICH
WAY TO WEED THROUGH. AND WE HEAR
OFTEN SOMETIMES MAYBE TO AN
EXTREME ABOUT EVERYBODY.
MOVING TO TEXAS I DON'T ARIZONA
I KNOW THAT'S NOT TRUE I KNOW
THAT WE ARE INNOVATIVE HERE AND
I KNOW THAT WE HAVE. A AS PEOPLE
LEAVE PEOPLE ARE COMING.
BUT I THINK ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT I CONTINUE TO HEAR AS A
THEME I NOT ONLY LOCALLY BUT I
HAVE DONE MANY MANY BUSINESS
TOWARD TAURUS IS. JUST THEY'RE
NOT SURE ABOUT WHERE TO START
AND WE HAVE WORKED IN THE JOBS
COMMITTEE ON THINGS LIKE MASTER
BUSINESS LICENCE SO THAT THEY
CAN GO ON. AND FIGURE OUT WHAT
IS UP AN OLD PIECE OF
LEGISLATION MAYBE WHAT'S
SOMETHING NEW ON TOP OF THAT
WHAT'S UP SOMETHING NEW THAT
THEY HAVE TO. ADJUST TO AND SO I
REALLY STRUGGLE WITH THIS BILL
BECAUSE ON THE ONE HAND WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT LET'S GO AHEAD AND
AUDIT AGENCIES AND LET'S GO
AHEAD AND MAKE SURE. THEY'RE
FOLLOWING UP AND THEM WERE
SAYING WELL WE DON'T WANT TO DO
THAT IN THIS CASE SO I THINK
THAT WE HAVE TO REALLY FACE THE
FACT THAT IF WE DON'T START TO
LOOK. AT ALL OF THE.
LAYERS AND LAYERS UPON UP
LEGISLATION THERE'S JUST A POINT
WHERE SMALL BUSINESSES
PARTICULARLY BUT ALSO OTHER
EMPLOYERS.
THEN EXAMPLE IS I MET WITH A
MANUFACTURER FURNITURE.
pFURNITURE IS NOT MADE HERE
ANYMORE ONES THAT ARE STILL
TRYING TO. DO THEIR WORK THEY
TALKED ABOUT YOU KNOW PEOPLE
COMING INTO THEIR BUSINESSES AND
THEY'RE GETTING FINE BECAUSE
THEY DON'T HAVE A POSTER ON THE
WALL. UP ABOUT SOMETHING SO
WE'RE TRYING WHEN I SAY
SOMETHING REGULATION I MEAN.
FOR EXAMPLE UP. WHERE IT MADE
THESE THINGS SO I AM I AM I
REALLY AM CONFLICTED ABOUT THIS
SO AT THIS POINT I'M GONNA STAY
OFF BUT? I I WOULD I KNOW WE I
HAVE MANY LABOR FRIENDS. OUT
THERE THAT THAT I DEFINITELY
SUPPORT THEIR. LOGIC ON THIS BUT
WE HAVE TO COME TO THE TABLE
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE EMPLOYERS
WE DON'T HAVE EMPLOYEES.
ANYBODY ELSE.
JOINT CLOSE CERTAINLY UP MEMBERS
ARE AT IT THIS BILL IS ALL ABOUT
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
WITH WE'VE TAILORED THIS.
PILL.
AS WHO OF TO SET THE THRESHOLD
THAT FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS OF
ECONOMIC COSTS TO THE STATE.
.
OR MORE AND SO AT THE NUMBER OF
REGULATIONS I THINK THAT WE'RE
GONNA REVIEW.
WILL PUBLIC P. LESS THAN TEN
AND THAT'S A SIGNIFICANT IMPACT
TO THE ENTIRE ECONOMY THAT'S
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS OF WORK TO
THE ENTIRE STATE.
AND OF COURSE WE SHOULD ALWAYS
ENCOURAGED AGENCIES A TO LOOK
BACK AND SEE IF THERE ARE
CONFLICTING REGULATIONS.
THAT NEED TO BE MODERNIZED OR
STREAMLINED.
AYE WE'VE HAD NUMEROUS
CONVERSATIONS.
WITH NUMEROUS MEMBERS ABOUT AND
AND MOST OF THE BILLS THAT WE
WILL WE INTRODUCE OUR BILLS THAT
WERE MODERNIZING SINCE.
BUT I HAVEN'T BEEN LOOKED AT
SINCE THE NINETEEN HUNDREDS
NINETEEN FIFTIES
AND SO IT IT THIS IN AND MY MIND
IS A BILL THAT IS VERY COMMON
SENSE. I WAS LOOKING WORK WERE
ENCOURAGING AGENCIES.
TO LOOK BACK IN STREAMLINED.
THE PROCESS HE'S A TO ENSURE
THAT THERE ISN'T DUPLICATIVE OF.
LAWS OR REGULATIONS AS SO THAT
WE CAN ENCOURAGE US BUT
BUSINESSES AND INDIVIDUALS AND
FAMILIES A THAT CAN COMPLY. WITH
THE REGULATIONS THAT ARE IN
PLACE BUT ALSO MOVE FORWARD WE
ARE THE ELECTED BODY.
AND TWO TWO FOUR FTA WE SHOULD
BE AS THAT AS A LEGISLATURE
ENCOURAGING ACCOUNTABILITY
ENCOURAGING OVERSIGHT AS AS YOU
MADAM CHAIR MENTIONED BEFORE TO
HAVE THIS COMMITTEE SERVE LIKE
THE CONGRESSIONAL. OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEE AT THIS IS BASED THERE
THERE ARE.
BASIE'S OF THIS BILL ON THE
FEDERAL LEVEL WITH THE
CONGRESSIONAL REVIEW ACT.
AND SO THIS.
DOES PROVIDE MORE OVERSIGHT AND
MORE TRANSPARENCY WHICH I THINK
THE PUBLIC DESERVES SO I
ENCOURAGE ABSENT WE ASK WHAT I
THOUGHT.
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS THAT AMOUNT
THAT'S EGGMAN. FELLOW MONTH AS A
MINNOW PATTERSON.
PATTERSON AYE BURKE.
FRAZIER.
FRAZIER NO LACKEY. LACKEY AYE
MEDINA. MEDINA NO KIRK SELMA.
HURT SOMEONE NOT LOADING.
YOU'VE ACTUALLY GOTTEN CAUGHT.
A DOCTOR WEBER.
AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY ONE.
YES.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR EGGMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I'M
PRESENTING AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY
ONE REGARDING SERVICE CONTRACTS
FOR THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA.
I WOULD LIKE TO SAY THAT I'VE
AGREED TO THE COMMITTEE'S
RECOMMENDATIONS IN TERMS OF
REDUCING THE TIME OF BEEN TO IS
AN ELIGIBLE TO CONTRACT. BUT NOT
COMPLY WITH THE PROVISIONS OF
THE BILL. WE'VE ALSO MADE
AMENDMENTS CLARIFY THE TRIGGER
FOR THE UC TO BE ABLE TO IN A
NON COMPLIANCE WITH TO BE IN NON
COMPLIANCE WITH THE BILL.
THIS IS WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT
TEMPORARY WORKERS THEY ARE MORE
LIKELY TO BE AN IMMIGRANT OR
PERSON OF COLOR. THEY'RE EARNING
LOWER WAGES WITH FEWER IF NO
BENEFITS THEY'RE LESS LIKELY TO
HAVE ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE AND
THEY'RE MORE LIKELY TO RELY UPON
PUBLIC ASSISTANCE.
THE QUESTION ONCE AGAIN BEFORE
THE LEGISLATURE'S WHAT THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA'S
CONTRACTING PRACTICES ARE
CONDEMNING LOW WAGE EMPLOYEES TO
POVERTY AND A RELIANCE ON TAX
FUNDED SOCIAL SERVICES.
THE STATE AUDITOR FOUND THAT
THERE IS NO WAY OF KNOWING WHAT
BECAUSE THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA DOES NOT KEEP TRACK
AND DOES NOT KEEP RECORDS.
SO WE'RE PROPOSING A MECHANISM
FOR TRANSPARENCY FOR THE
UNIVERSITY.
BIN IS ARE REQUIRED TO PROVIDE
INFORMATION ABOUT EACH
EMPLOYEE'S PAY AND BENEFITS TO
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
CHANCES OFFICE.
THE CHANCES OFFICE WOULD BE
REQUIRED TO POST THIS
INFORMATION ON A PUBLIC
ACCESSIBLE WEBSITE.
IF THE VENDOR FAILS TO PROVIDE
THE INFORMATION THEY WOULD NOT
BE ELIGIBLE TO CONTRACT WITH THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA FOR TWO
YEARS.
IF UNIVERSITY AT CALIFORNIA
CONTINUES TO CONTRACT WITH
VENDORS WOULD NOT IN COMPLIANCE
WITH THE REQUIREMENTS OF THIS
BILL THE LEGISLATURE WILL DEDUCT
THE AMOUNT OF THE CONTRACT FROM
THEIR BUDGET ALLOCATION.
THIS WOULD PROVIDE CLARITY ABOUT
WHETHER THE UNIVERSITY IS
ENFORCING ITS OWN MINIMUM WAGE
POLICIES AND WHETHER THESE
EMPLOYEES RECEIVE ANY HEALTH OR
RETIREMENT BENEFITS.
AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY ONE BILL
WILL ALSO ALLOW THE LAWMAKERS TO
GAUGE THE EXTENT TO WHICH THESE
CONTRACTS
SHE OF COST TO THE STATE BY
THESE EMPLOYEES HAVING NOTE RELY
ON PUBLIC ASSISTANCE.
HERE WITH ME TODAY TO SUPPORT
THE BILL IS CLAUDIA PER PRODUCT
FROM ASKED ME LOCAL THIRTY TWO
NINETY NINE. AND ALSO JULIA
WATERS FROM ASK ME FOR TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE.
THANK YOU.
FIRST PRODUCED BECAUSE SUPPORT
PLEASE.
GREAT THANK YOU GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MONEY WAS CLAUDIA PER
PRADA AND I'M THE RESEARCH
DIRECTOR FOR OUSTING LOCAL
THIRTY TWO NINETY NINE. THE
LARGEST UNION AT THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND SERVICE IN
PATIENT CARE TECHNICAL WORKERS
THROUGHOUT THE UC SYSTEM THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY. TO
TESTIFY IN FRONT OF YOU TODAY.
I'M HERE TO REGISTER THE UNION
SUPPORT FOR AB TWENTY THREE
SIXTY ONE WHICH QUITE SIMPLY
REQUEST THAT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA MAINTAIN A PUBLICLY
X. A ASSESSABLE DATABASE OF ITS
CDVA SERVICE CONTRACTORS.
THE ANTENNA OF THE LEGISLATION
IS TWO FOLD FIRST PROVIDE THE
LEGISLATURE A VEHICLE TO MONITOR
UC'S PROGRESS IN ADDRESSING THE
STATE AUDITOR'S CRITICISMS OF
ITS CONTRACTING OUT PRACTICES.
AND SECOND CONFIRM THE EXTENT OF
UC'S USE OF LOW WHICH
CONTRACTORS.
LAST YEAR THE STATE AUDITOR
FOUND UC'S CONTRACTING OUT.
RESULTS NOT JUST IN THE
DISPLACEMENT BUT ALSO IN THE
AVOIDANCE OF HIRING YOU SEE
SERVICE WORKERS.
YOU SEE CONTRACTORS ARE PAID UP
TO EIGHT DOLLARS AND FIFTY CENTS
LESS THAN YOU SEE SERVICE
WORKERS DURING COMPARABLE WORK.
UC'S OUTSOURCING OF SERVICE WORK
IS NOT JUST TEMPORARY.
ADDITIONALLY YOU SEE DOES NOT
ADEQUATELY MEASURE SUPPORT COST
SAVINGS ARE EFFICIENCIES
RESULTING FROM OUTSOURCING.
AND YOU SEE RENEWS CONTRACTS
REPEATEDLY OFTEN WITHOUT HEARING
TO COMPETITIVE BIDDING
REQUIREMENTS.
THEREFORE THE INFORMATION
PROVIDED UNDER AB TWENTY THREE
SIX.
ONE WOULD PROVIDE THE
LEGISLATURE AND OTHER INTERESTED
STAKEHOLDERS THE ABILITY TO
MONITOR UC'S PROGRESS IN
ADDRESSING.
THE AUDITOR'S CONCERNS.
THE UNIVERSITY WOULD BE AFFECTED
ONLY IF IT FAILS TO PROVIDE THE
CONTRACTOR DATA OR FAILS TO
DECLARE AN UNCOOPERATIVE
CONTRACTOR UNQUALIFIED BETTER
FOR FUTURE WORK IN OTHER WORDS.
YOU SEE CAN AVOID CONSEQUENCE BY
TAKING SIMPLE AND REASONABLE
STOPS.
LASTLY THE UNION'S RESEARCH
REPORT FINDS THAT THE AVERAGE
STARTING PAY FOR LATINO BLACK
WORKERS IN AUS THREE REPRESENTED
TITLES IS AT LEAST TWENTY
PERCENT LOWER THAN WHITE WORKERS
AND THAT THE NUMBER OF BLACK
WORKERS AT UC HAS DECREASED BY
THIRTY SEVEN PERCENT SINCE
NINETEEN NINETY SIX. WHILE
CONTRACTOR SURVEYS SUGGEST
OUTSOURCED WORKERS ARE MORE
LIKELY TO BE BLACK THAN YOU SEE
SERVICE WORKERS.
AS A THIRD LARGEST EMPLOYER IN
THE STATE UC'S A DRIVER BOTH
SOCIAL MOBILITY INEQUALITY
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. ITS
EMPLOYMENT PRACTICES HAVE
IMPLICATIONS NOT JUST FOR THE
UNIVERSITY BUT FOR THE ENTIRE
STATE THEREFORE SHINING A LIGHT.
ON ITS CONTRACTING OUT PRACTICES
IS A MATTER OF STATE WHAT
CONCERN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU EXCURSIONS BEGIN
SUPPORT.
OKAY SO TECHNICALLY TECHNICAL
TECHNICALLY ONE ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS.
ALRIGHT IT WAS BEGIN OPPOSITION
TODAY.
THERE'S MORE SUPPORTS MORE
SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MAP RIGHT
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE TEAMSTERS
AND SPORT THANK YOU.
MICHAEL YOUNG WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
ROUGHLY HER SUPPORT.
JUDGE WILL WILL GO WITH THE
AMERICAN FEDERATION OF STATE
COUNTY AND MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES
AND SUPPORT.
ANYWAY SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO.
QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM THE
MISTER MEDIA.
A THANK YOU AGAIN TO THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD I
THINK IT IS MUCH NEEDED.
I I THINK AS LONG AS YOU SEE.
ENGAGES IN CONTRACTING OUT.
THE LEGISLATURE WILL BE
CONCERNED AND RIGHTLY SO.
I I I HEARD ABOUT.
.
VALET PARKERS AT UCLA WHO WERE
BEING PAID SUBSTANTIALLY LESS.
THEN YOU SEE OTHER UCLA
EMPLOYEES AND AND AND AND AND
ACTUALLY LOST THEIR JOBS.
.
DURING THE PROCESS.
I'VE WE HEARD THE BILL AND AND
HIGHER EDUCATION WE'RE GOT
THROUGH A QUESTION THE
AMENDMENTS THAT YOU TOOK I THINK
MAKE THE BILL OF BETTER WHO.
.
IT IT WORKED WITH YOU SEE A
LITTLE BIT AND.
IN THE PART OF THE IF I.
AND IF YOU WOULD CLARIFY FOR ME.
.
THAT.
IT WOULD ONLY.
PASSED THAT MANY BE KEPT FROM
YOU SEE IF THEY KNOWLEDGEABLE IN
IT IF THEY HAD THE INFORMATION
AND FAILED TO PROVIDE IT MY.
CORRECT IN THAT SO THE
CONTRACTORS FAILED TO GIVE THEM
THE INFORMATION.
THERE WOULD NOT BE PENALIZED
FOR.
INFORMATION THAT THEY MAY NOT
HAVE MY RIGHT AND RECOMMEND THEY
WOULD NOT THAT BE PENALIZED IF
THEY CONTINUE TO CONTRACT WITH
SOMEONE WHO REFUSED TO COOPERATE
WITH HIM.
I I I I THINK IT'S A GOOD BILL I
SUPPORT IT WHOLEHEARTEDLY AND
WILL SUPPORT IT AGAIN IN THIS
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU
THEY CONSIDER IT A MOTION.
TREASURY THINK MADAM CHAIR.
SO I'VE SEEN THIS BILL IN THE
SNIFFER FARMS ARE.
THE LAST THREE YEARS.
AND IT'S BEEN VETOED AND I'VE
SUPPORTED EACH AND EVERY TIME.
OF AS A FORMER CONTRACTOR
INSTEAD OF CALIFORNIAN.
UNDERSTANDING THE DIFFERENTIAL
BETWEEN TEMPORARY WORKER AND AND
FULL TIME.
EMPLOYEE WHOSE VESTED IN AND
LOYAL AND AND ALL OF THE THINGS
THAT COME WITH THAT.
NOT TO DISPARAGE THE TEMPORARY
WORK FORCE I MEAN THAT THEY HAVE
A.
A PLACE TO TO TO FIT INTO THIS
MOBILE.
WE WE LOOK IT TIME FRAMES THAT.
WE'VE NOT COME TO A DEFINITION
WHERE THEY IT'S UC'S MUST GO TO
A FULL TIME EMPLOYEE.
WE ALL WE'VE GONE AND SAID
THERE.
AT NEW REPORTING IN ALL OF THIS.
BUT I MEAN THERE HAS TO BE A
JUSTIFICATION SAVE. THAT
I'M A TEMPORARY PLACE SIXTEEN
NINETY WHATEVER THE
DETERMINATION.
THAT WORKS FOR BOTH SIDES I
GUESS BUT LET'S GET TO THE HAD
POINT AND AND AND AND FINALIZES.
A NEW GOVERNOR'S VETO THIS EACH
AND EVERY TIME AND I HOPE YOU'VE
ADDRESSED.
THE VETO MESSAGE AGAIN.
.
BUT.
I MEAN THERE'S NOTHING BETTER
THAN A FULL TIME EMPLOYEE.
WE WHEN WE NEED FELONS THAT'S
WHEN WE USE THE TEMPORARY
EMPLOYEES RIGHT OF INSTITUTIONAL
KNOWLEDGE IS GAINED BY FULL TIME
IN PLACES ABSOLUTELY VALUABLE.
BUT LET'S
FIGURE OUT A DETERMINATION ON
THE DATE OF. WHEN TEMPORARY
STOPS IN FULL TIME NEEDS TO BE
AT HOME BOOK I WILL AGAIN
SUPPORT THIS BILL AND I HOPE
YOU'RE SUCCESSFUL. THROUGHOUT
THE PATH.
BUT.
LET'S WORK ON THAT TOO.
WE'RE IN AGREEMENT.
THANK YOU.
I ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM THE
THE COMMITTEE. OKAY DOT WEBER
LIKE CLOTHES SURE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR ALL THE COMMENTS AND
FOR THOSE WHO CAME UP TO SUPPORT
AND FOR ASK ME FOR COSTLY
WORKING ON THAT THIS IS A MAJOR
ISSUE BECAUSE. EUROPE
CALIFORNIA'S ONE OF THE LARGEST
EMPLOYERS IN THE STATE AND AT
THIS HOUSE IN IN THIS IN THIS A
LEGISLATURE WE HAVE TAKEN MANY
STEPS WITH REGARDS TO WHAT IS.
WHAT WE THINK WILL ELECT
ELIMINATE POVERTY AND AND HELP
FOLKS TO GO ON TO DEVELOP AND SO
THEREFORE IT BECOMES IMPORTANT
WE DON'T HAVE? A ONE MESSAGE
THAT WE PUT OUT THERE AND THEN
WE HAVE ONE OF OUR MAJORS
EMPLOYERS DOING SOMETHING
TOTALLY DIFFERENT AND CREATING
POVERTY IN TERMS OF WORKFORCE
RATHER THAN IT INSISTING US.
LIFTING PEOPLE OUT OF THE POT
OUT OF POVERTY SO TWENTYTHREE
SIXTY ONE IS REALLY ABOUT
TRANSPARENCY INITIALLY NOW
BECAUSE THEY HAVE NOT BEEN
REQUIRED TO KEEP GOOD RECORDS
AND SO THEREFORE. I DON'T
OPPOSED TO KNOW WHAT WE'RE
FIGHTING IN OUR FIGHTING BUT WE
NEED TO BRING CHANGE ABOUT THIS
IS ONE OF THE FIRST STEPS FOR
DOING THAT. UP SO I RESPECTFULLY
ASK WHAT I BUILD FORTS AB TWENTY
SIX THIRTY ONE THING TWENTY
THREE SIXTY ONE.
VICTOR WAS COLOR.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED AS
AMENDED AND BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS THAT
AMOUNT THIS EGGMAN. THAT AMOUNT
IS EGGMAN I'VE PATTERSON
BURKE.
BURKE I'VE FRAZIER FRAZIER AYE
LACKEY LACKEY NO MEDINA. MEDINA
AYE QUIRK SILVA QUIRK SILVA AYE.
IF YOU'RE A MEASURE GOES UP.
AND I SEE MISS WALDRON OUT
THERE.
SWELLED WEDNESDAY'S PRESENTING.
TWENTY EIGHTY SEVEN THAT DOES
ENJOY A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
SUPPORT SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I AM VERY
EXCITED TO ACTUALLY PRESENT THIS
BILL TODAY IN SOME. COUPLE YEARS
IN THE WORKS.
.
TO PRESENT AB TWENTY EIGHTY
SEVEN A BILL TO BRING CALIFORNIA
GOVERNMENT INTO THE TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY IF IT'S EVEN POSSIBLE.
CALIFORNIA IS WOEFULLY BEHIND IN
MAKING USE OF TECHNOLOGY TO
STREAMLINE OPERATIONS IMPROVE
PUBLIC TRANSPARENCY.
OUR STATE MUST ENCOURAGE
MODERNIZATION TO CREATE FAMILY
FRIENDLY WORKPLACES REDUCE
SPENDING INCREASE EFFICIENCIES
AND CYBERSECURITY STREAMLINE
PROCESSES AND REDUCE CARBON
EMISSIONS.
INNOVATIONS IN TECHNOLOGY CAN
HELP LEGISLATIVE JUDICIAL AND
EXECUTIVE BRANCH OPERATE
EFFICIENTLY AND ENCOURAGE MORE
WOMEN TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
WORKFORCE AND CREATE THE PUBLIC
TRANSPARENCY WE NEED.
AND CALIFORNIA'S MISSING OUT AND
SO MANY OF THE BENEFITS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE MODERNIZE
WORKPLACE AND I JUST WANNA TO
SQUEEZE THEN.
.
THE ISSUE OF WOMEN AND A COUPLE
YEARS AGO THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS HAD
DONE AN OFFSITE MEETING I. WAS
ABLE TO GET SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT WERE PRESENTED IN ITS SHOWS
ONE OF THE BARRIERS TO WOMEN.
BEING IN THE EVEN ELECTED OFFICE
ORDER THE THE BARRIERS TO WOMEN
IN THE WORKFORCE. AND IT SAYS
THAT ABOUT SEVEN IN TEN
AMERICANS SEVENTY ONE PERCENT
SAY THE COUNTRY NEEDS TO
CONTINUE TO MAKE CHANGES TO GIVE
MEN AND WOMEN EQUALITY IN THE
WORKPLACE.
AND THE VIEW THAT THE COUNTRY
NEEDS TO CONTINUE MAKING CHANGES
TO ACHIEVE GENDER EQUALITY IN
THE WORKPLACE THIS PARTICULAR
COMMON AMONG WOMEN SEVENTY SEVEN
PERCENT.
SO WE HAVE A LONG WAY TO GO AND
I BELIEVE TECHNOLOGY A
MODERNIZING THAN LOOKING AT EVEN
ON THE LEGISLATURE THE WAY WE
CONDUCT BUSINESS THE
EFFICIENCIES THE SCHEDULES.
THINGS LIKE THAT COULD BE
LOOKED.
THE ADMINISTRATIVELY ADJUSTED
FROM.
WHY DOES THE SENATE THE LAST
TIME WE AMENDED THE BILL ON THE
SIDE OF FLOOR THEY WANTED TEN
PRINTED COPIES SO THEY COULD CUT
AND PASTE?
WHY CAN'T THE D. M. V. PROVIDE
THE DEAL FORTY FOUR FORM FOR
ANYONE WHO HAS A CHILD LEARNING
TO DRIVE IF THE CALL IS IN ON
THE PHONE THEY DON'T HAVE IT AT
THE? AT THE DMV YOU CAN'T GET IT
ONLINE.
SO THERE'S A LOT OF THINGS THAT
WE COULD CHANGE.
BECAUSE TODAY I HAVE GENERAL
COOK FROM THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION TO SUPPORT THE BILL.
MISTER COOK.
THANK YOU THE CHAIR OF THE
COMMITTEE MANY MISTRAL COOK I
REPRESENT THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION WE HEAR TODAY IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY.
EIGHTY SEVEN UP.
I'M HERE TO JUST GIVE A IN THE
BUSINESS AND INDUSTRY
PERSPECTIVE ON WHY THIS NOW IF
YOU.
BY STATES AND GOVERNMENTS.
ENCOURAGES INVESTMENT FROM THE
PRIVATE SECTOR BECAUSE WE CAN
RELY ON THE STATE TO EFFICIENTLY
AND EFFECTIVELY DELIVER DELIVER
THE SERVICES THAT WE RELY UPON
AYE IT ENCOURAGES US TO LOCATE.
OUR FACILITIES AND EXPAND OUR
FACILITIES IN CALIFORNIA AYE
IT'S ALSO. IN ENGINE OF ECONOMIC
GROWTH BECAUSE THE TECHNOLOGIES
THAT THE STATE GOVERNMENT WILL
BE INVESTING IN ARE PRODUCED BY
CALIFORNIA COMPUTER AND
ELECTRONIC MANUFACTURERS WHICH
ARE PIONEERS IN LEADING THE
WORLD INNOVATION. BUT ON THE
FLIP SIDE BUT THAT THE THE
PITFALLS OF NOT MODERNIZING CAN
BE SEEN.
IN OTHER STATES BUT IF YOU'VE
BEEN FOLLOWING THE NEWS WE'VE
SEEN REPORTS OUT OF BOB. ATLANTA
GEORGIA WHICH THAT I'M.
FAMILIAR WITH THE SPEND WHAT
TIME IN A THEY CURRENTLY
SUFFERED.
THEY THOUGHT SUFFERED A CYBER
ATTACK EARLIER IN APRIL WHICH
SHUT DOWN.
CITY GOVERNMENT TO FORCE THEM
TO GO BACK TO PAPER AND PENCIL
TO TO DELIVER CITY.
SERVICES THAT AND IT SHUT DOWN
PUBLIC EMERGENCY SERVICES SO THE
FAILURE TO MODERNIZE HAS EXTREME
PITFALLS FOR OUR STATE.
GOVERNMENT AND MODERNIZING ONLY
PRODUCES BENEFITS WE'RE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF BILL ME
COURAGE AND YOUR I'VE.
THANK YOU MUCH YOU KNOW SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL TODAY.
AND BASS BEGIN OPPOSITION.
QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
NOW I THINK IT'S A FINE BILL AND
I HAVE BEEN VIRTUALLY PAPERLESS
SINCE I'VE STARTED HERE AND IT
DID IT'S POSSIBLE TO DO AND BUT
PEOPLE STILL TRY THROW PAPER AT
MEALTIME.
I'VE TO FIGHT BACK AGAINST IT.
A I MAYBE ONE DAY BELIEVE
BUILDER TELECOMMUTE AS THE
LEGISLATURE.
JOKING RIGHT UP THAT BIG OFF
SOME.
IT DOESN'T ENJOYED YOU PASSING A
US SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS A REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON RULES THAT
AMOUNT THIS EGGMAN ELEMENT THAT
EGGMAN AYE PATTERSON.
BURKE.
BURKE AYE FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE LACKEY LACKEY AYE
MEDINA MEDINA AYE QUIRK SILVA
QUIRK SILVA AYE.
THE BILL'S OUT SWANKY FROM
GRADUATION.
BONTA
.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
COLLEAGUES.
AND STAFF I THINK FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT AB TWENTY
SEVEN FORTY NINE TODAY TWENTY
SEVEN FORTY NINE WOULD SIMPLY
ADD. MOBILE FRIENDLY THE
CALIFORNIA GOVERNMENT CODE TO
ENSURE THAT STATE GOVERNMENT
WEBSITES ACCESSIBLE.
TO THOSE WITH A MOBILE DEVICE
THAT WOULD ALSO INCLUDE A
SECTION THAT ENSURES FUTURE
STATE GOVERNMENT WEBSITES WILL
BE MOBILE FRIENDLY AS WELL THINK
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT ACCESS
ISSUE GOOD GOVERNMENT ISSUE
EQUITY ISSUE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I THINK
YOU'RE MUCH.
YOU KNOW WHAT'S WE COULDN'T OF
SUPPORT TODAY.
THE COMMAND CHAIR ROB GROWS
CLOSER WITH ADOBE.
AT ADOBE WE BELIEVE THAT.
GOVERNMENT SHOULD BE SENSIBLE
BY ALL INDIVIDUALS AND WE THINK
THE SUCH SECTOR FOR THE
COMMITMENT TO THAT ACCESS AND
LIKE TO THINK IT'S SUMMER.
BONTA FOR FURTHERING IT WITH
THIS LEGISLATION THE NUMBERS ARE
STAGGERING ON THE SO SMART
PHONES AND SPECIAL WITH YOUNG
FOLKS AS WELL AS ECONOMICALLY
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND
THE NUMBERS CONTINUE TO
INCREASE.
THIS BILL IS IN LINE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
TECHNOLOGIES VISION TWENTY
TWENTY PLAN.
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY IT
CODIFIES THIS LEGISLATURE'S
COMMITMENT FOR MOBILE FRIENDLY
THANK YOU.
THIS PERSON.
GOOD MORNING JOHN FLORES WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY
WESTERN CENTER REPRESENTS LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIANS INCLUDING
MANY THAT YOU STATE ARE COUNTY
ADMINISTERED PUBLIC PROGRAMS
SUCH AS MEDICARE I'LL CAO WORKS
CAL FRESH. IN COUNTY BENEFITS
PROGRAMS MANY LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS DO NOT HAVE
PERSONAL COMPUTERS ARE SMART AND
SMARTPHONES ARE THE ONLY MEANS
OF ACCESSING GOVERNMENT WEBSITE.
LAST YEAR THERE'S A BIT OF A
KERFUFFLE MADE DURING THAT
DEBATE ABOUT REPEALING THE
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT WHEN A
CONGRESS PERSON SAID MAYBE IT
LOW INCOME PEOPLE SHOULD BY
HEALTH INSURANCE INSTEAD OF
BUYING IPHONES. WELL THE FACT IS
THAT THE SMARTPHONE IS OFTEN
THEIR LAND LINE IT'S OFTEN THEIR
PERSONAL COMPUTER AND SOME OF
THE CLIENTS THAT I PERSONALLY
HAVE REPRESENTED.
THE PHONE PART OF IT DOESN'T
EVEN WORK BUT THEY'RE USING THE
WIFI PART FOR THEIR SOUL
COMMUNICATION WITH. YOU KNOW
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES WITH PEOPLE
THAT THEY'RE WORKING WITH.
SO THIS AT IS REALLY AN
IMPORTANT EQUITY ISSUE AND THEN
FOR THAT ANOTHER PIECE OF THE
BILL DOES IS LOOKING AT THE
DISABILITY ACCESS AS WELL BEFORE
GOVERNMENT WEBSITE GOES LIVE.
AND I KNOW FOR A LOT OF SENIORS
THAT I'VE WORKED WITH THEY WOULD
UC'S WEBSITES MORE BUT THEY
CAN'T SEE THEM. SUPPOSED TO ADD
THAT PIECE IN IS ALSO IMPORTANT.
AND THEN RECENTLY A WESTERN
CENTER HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
WORK WITH D. H. CS AND COVERED
CALIFORNIA ON IMPROVING THE COW
HERE'S COMPUTER SYSTEM. AND
DURING THAT PROCESS WE WERE
LOOKING AT BOTH THEIR WEBSITE
AND THE MOBILE SITE AT THE SAME
TIME. AND ACTUALLY HAD THE
BENEFIT OF MAKING THE WEBSITE
BETTER FOR EVERYBODY BECAUSE
WHEN YOU'RE LOOKING AT A SMALL
SCREEN AND YOU REALIZE YOU CAN
ONLY FIT SO MUCH INFORMATION ON
IT. YOU HAVE TO BE SUCCINCT AND
YOU HAVE TO PUT INFORMATION IN A
WAY THAT PEOPLE CAN DIE JUSTICE.
SO WE THINK THE AUTHOR FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP AND WE'RE PROUD TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
GIVE ANYBODY ELSE BEGIN SUPPORT
TODAY.
ANYBODY SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL.
THE COMMISSION THE COMMITTEE.
AS AS A MOM OF FOUR MILLENNIALS
HERE WHEN I SAY THE HOT WATER IN
THEIR TWENTIES. THIS IS THE ONLY
THING THEY USE TO. COMMUNICATE
AND LESS IS MORE MEANING ONE
WORD. BUT. PARTICULARLY FOR BOYS
HOW ARE YOU FINE.
BUT I THINK THAT AGAIN IT'S NOT
ITS COMPANION TO WE JUST HEARD
WE HAVE TO UPDATE IN MOVE. BLOOD
SO THAT. EVERYBODY CAN BE PART
OF GETTING INFORMATION
THANK YOU.
I WASN'T UP OF.
BUT WITH ONE OF THE NONPROFIT SO
I WORK WITH CERTAIN IN MY
DISTRICT CONCILIO AND THEY WERE
THEY WERE TALKING ABOUT THIS
VERY ISSUE THAT THEY WERE MOVING
THEIR WEBSITE TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
IT BE. A SMARTPHONE ASSESSABLE
JUST BECAUSE THEY THEY REALIZE
THE MAJORITY OF THE PEOPLE THAT
THEY SERVE EVEN THOUGH THE PGA
SENIORS MAY NOT HAVE IT BUT THE
THEIR KIDS HAVE AN IPHONE. AND
THAT IF THE AND IF THEY CAN'T
DOESN'T COME UP THEY CAN'T FIND
THE AGENCY. SO I THINK IT'S A
IMPERATIVE IN AND SMART AND
STATE GOVERNMENT SHOULD FOLLOW.
WE GOT CLOSE MISTER BOND
RESPECT AFTER I DON'T THINK THE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS BUT A MONTH AS
EGGMAN PIE AND A MONTH EGGMAN
AYE PATTERSON. BURKE
BURKE I FRAZIER FRAZIER AYE
LACKEY LACKEY AYE MEDINA. MEDINA
AYE QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE.
A BILLS OUT THANK YOU MISTER
BONTA EGGMAN CARE THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES THAT YOU STAFF
IF YOU MISTER CALDERON YOU.
ALL WAS PRESENTING AB TWENTY
NINE SEVEN ONE.
AGAIN DEALING WITH.
REGULATIONS AND REVIEW AND
OVERSIGHT.
WELCOME BACK TO SCOTT.
TAKE MY TIME AND READ MY
COMMENTS VERY SLOWLY IT'S ALLOW
MISTER COOLEY ENOUGH I'M GOING
TO BE SPEAKING AT A RALLY RIGHT
NOW SO ATHLETES GET.
I THAT YOU MET YOUR MEMBERS.
MAINTAINING A BUSINESS CLIMATE
WHERE INNOVATION IS WELCOMED AND
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS ARE
OBSERVED IS CRUCIAL FOR THE
HEALTH OF CALIFORNIA'S THRIVING
ECONOMY HOWEVER CALIFORNIA
BUSINESSES SHARE A COMMON
COMPLAINT REGARDING THE
CHALLENGES POSED. BY THE
MULTITUDE OF STATE REGULATIONS
OVER TIME THE STATUTES THIS
LEGISLATIVE BODY PASSES AN AXE
CAN RESULT IN DUPLICATE OF A
CONSISTENT OR AND OUTDATED
REGULATIONS WHICH CAN DISCOURAGE
INNOVATION. AND NEW BUSINESS
VENTURES THIS BILL SEEKS TO
ADDRESS THIS BY CONDUCTING A ONE
TIME TOP TO BOTTOM THOROUGH
REVIEW OF ALL STATE REGULATIONS
TO ENSURE CONSISTENCY AND
CLARITY WITHOUT UNDERMINING
PUBLIC PROTECTIONS.
DUPLICATIVE BEEN INCONSISTENT
REGULATIONS DISCOURAGE
INNOVATION AND NEW BUSINESS
VENTURES WHILE CONTRIBUTING
MINIMALLY.
PROTECTION OF CONSUMERS THE
ENVIRONMENT AN EMPLOYEE'S AB
TWENTY NINE SEVEN ONE WILL LEAD
TO MORE STREAMLINED REGULATIONS
IMPROVE GOVERNANCE OVERALL BY
IDENTIFYING UNNECESSARY NOT DATA
REGULATIONS.
YOU KNOW THE POINT OF THE BILL
IS THAT WE HEAR ALL THE TIME WE
TALKED TO DIFFERENT BUSINESS
VENTURES WHETHER BIG OR SMALL
BUSINESSES IS THAT YOU KNOW
THERE ARE A LOT OF TIMES WHERE
IN ORDER TO BE IN COMPLIANCE
THIS REGULATION ABOUT A COMPLAIN
WITH THIS REGULATION AND. SO I
BASICALLY JUST HAVE TO CHOOSE
ONE ARE AND PAY THE FINE FOR THE
OTHER ONE FOR BEING BY IN
VIOLATION OF THAT OTHER
REGULATION AND SO THE POINT OF
THE BILL IS JUST. TO KNOW IT'S
JUST IT'S IT IT'S A STUDY BILL.
TAKE A LOOK AT ALL THE DAY
REGULATIONS THAT WE HAVE IN THE
STATE OTHER DUPLICATIVE WHETHER
IDENTICAL REGULATIONS THAT. YOU
KNOW THEY'RE THEY'RE SIMILAR IN
NATURE TO DO THE SAME THING.
OR ARE THEIR OUTDATED
REGULATIONS AND WE WE HAD TERM
LIMITED TIMES WHERE MEMBERS ARE
CONSTANTLY PASSING BILLS ARE
CONSTANTLY PASSING MEASURES ARE.
AND THERE COULD BE ON THE BOOKS
OUTDATED REGULATIONS THAT ARE NO
LONGER ACTIVE AYE RELEVANT TODAY
AND TODAY'S JOB MARKET THIS
ISN'T UNDERMINING TYPE WORKER
PROTECTION OR DO ANYTHING ELSE.
OTHER THAN JUST SAID NO BECAUSE
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO KNOW
AND YOU KNOW WHAT EVEN IF THE
CITY COMES BACK AND SAYS YOU
KNOW WHAT THEY'RE NOT UPDATED
OUR. OR RELEVANT REGULATIONS ON
THE BOOK WILL GOOD AT LEAST WE
DIDN'T KNOW BUT AT LEAST IT
GIVES US THE POWER IS THE
LEGISLATURE TO HAVE A STEADY
LOOK AT IT AND TAKE ANY ACTION
OR MAYBE TAKE NO ACTION AT ALL.
BUT RELEASED JUSTIN ALLEN THAT'S
THE POINT OF THIS BILL AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
AND LIKE INTRODUCED MY JOINT
AUTHOR. OUT THERE WITH ME TODAY
MISTER COOLEY AND ALSO HAVE
NATURAL COOK REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURES AND
TECHNOLOGY SOCIO XIN DEFENSIVE
LINE SUPPORT.
TO COOLEY.
WELL I'M.
I AM PLEASED TO BE HERE AND TEST
TRANSPORT OF THIS BILL I THINK
IT'S VERY REASONABLE.
THAT WE SHOULD ASK AGENCIES TO
LOOK FOR DUPLICATIVE
INCONSISTENT OUTDATED.
INCOMPATIBLE REGULATIONS.
I ACTUALLY THINK ARE AS
MAJORITY LEADER JUST SAID THIS
IS A PART OF US.
LONGER TERM MEMBER SORT OF A
CERTAIN THE DIGNITY OF
GOVERNMENTS ARE RESPONSIBILITY.
I THINK THAT IS A VERY IMPORTANT
VITAL PUBLIC FUNCTION.
AND.
.
I THINK MORE VITAL TODAY THEN
PERHAPS AT ANY OTHER TIME.
I HAVE IN MY HAND.
AND I'M FLOW FROM THE CHAMBERS
OF JUSTICE ANTHONY KENNEDY.
A PERSONAL NOTE TO ME FIFTEEN
YEARS AGO WHEN I BECAME A CITY
COUNCIL MEMBER.
AND JUSTICE KENNEDY REFLECTING
UPON THE FORMATION OF GOVERNMENT
ADDED SITTING CALIFORNIA.
WROTE ARE.
SELF GOVERNMENT MUST NOT BE AN
ABSTRACT IDEAL.
BUT MUST BE A REALITY.
AND WE MUST BE UNCEASING.
IN OUR EFFORTS TO MAKE IT MORE
EFFECTIVE AND RESPECTED BY OUR
PEOPLE.
AND I ACTUALLY THINK THAT FOR US
SAYS LAWMAKERS.
TO CALL UPON THE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH TO LOOK AT THE BODY OF
REGULATIONS.
THE PEOPLE CALIFORNIA SUBJECT
TO.
AND LOOK TO SEE WHETHER THERE
IT'S REGULATIONS WHICH IS
INCONSISTENT UPDATING
DUPLICATIVE.
IS ACTUALLY A GOVERNMENTAL
FUNCTION OF THE LEGISLATURE TO
SUPPORT THE RESPECT
OF OUR SYSTEM OF GOVERNMENT.
AND AS I SAY I THINK IN THIS
ERA.
CONTINUE WITH WHAT WE CONTEND
WITH AROUND THE COUNTRY CUTS IN
A SPECIALLY VITAL FUNCTION TO
LEAD ON.
SO I'M DELIGHTED TO BE HERE
IT'S.
AND THEY'VE DONE A LOT OF WORK
ON THIS MISTER COOLEY MISTER
COOK.
THANK YOU THE CHAIR OF THE
COMMITTEE MANY MISTER AL COOK I
REPRESENT THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION WE'RE HERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY NINE
SEVENTY ONE. OF THE BILL. AS WAS
STATED EARLIER DOES NOT HAVE ANY
MANDATES TO ROLL BACK REPEAL
REGULATIONS IT IT REQUIRES A
STATE AGENCY SIMPLY IDENTIFIED
OF REGULATIONS THAT ARE.
OVERLAPPING DUPLICATIVE OR OUT
OF DATE.
AND THEN REPORT BACK TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR TO
YOU THEN DECIDE WHAT TO DO WITH
THIS ALLOWS US TO DO IS TO UP
CUT THROUGH ANY SORT OF BIAS
SEIZE THE DOG WHEN THAT WE SEE
ON. ON BOTH SIDES TO WHAT
REGULATIONS DO AND WILL DO.
NO MATTER HOW GOOD OUR
PROSPECTIVE ANALYSIS IS AND IN
CALIFORNIA IT IS QUITE GOOD A.
WE DO IT WHEN WE KNOW THE LEAST
ABOUT WHAT THE EFFECTS ARE
REGULATION GOING TO BE IN SO
IT'S INCUMBENT UPON A HEALTHY
REGULATORY SYSTEM TO EXAMINE THE
EFFECTS. AND THEN MOVE IN
ACCORDANCE OF WHAT'S HAPPENING
IN TRACKING WITH REALITY UP THE
BENEFIT OF OF AND HAVING THIS
LOOK BACK LOOK BACK MECHANISM.
THAT WE CAN SEE AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL TWENTY ELEVEN THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION CONDUCTED A
SIMILAR OF RETROSPECT REVIEW
MONTH ITS STATE AGENCIES IN THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WAS ABLE TO
SAVE UP THIRTY SEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR IN CUTTING
UNNECESSARY DUPLICATIVE.
OVERLAPPING REGULATION WE
EXPECT CALIFORNIA TO RECEIVE A
SIMILAR SCALE BENEFIT.
UP THIS IS IS WHY THIS MEASURES
RECOMMENDED.
BY GOOD GOVERNMENT EXPERTS ON
BOTH SIDES IS RECOMMENDED BY THE
LITTLE HOOVER COMMISSION TWENTY
ELEVEN WAS RECOMMENDED BY THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE AND
TWENTY SEVENTEEN.
AND WE. WERE LOOKING AT THE
COMMITTEE OUR ANALYSIS THAT
WE'VE SEEN SOME OF. WHAT THE
CONCERNS ARE?
?
THIS IS. A BIT
THE METHODOLOGY IN THE BILL IS
NOT PRESCRIPTIVE ON HOW AGENCIES
NEED TO REVIEW THE REGULATIONS
IT PRESERVES FLEXIBILITY ON HOW
TO CONDUCT THESE REVIEWS. WHAT
WE SAW IN THIS WAS CONDUCTED AT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL IS THAT
AGENCIES DEVELOP THEIR OWN
PLANTS A RETROSPECTIVE REVIEW SO
HERE?
THIS COULD BE ROLLED INTO
ORDINARY AGENCY OPERATIONS I
COULD BE DONE THROUGH PUBLIC
NOTICE AND COMMENT COULD BE
CONTRACTED TO A THIRD PARTY OR
AGENCIES COULD CHOOSE TO DO IT
THEMSELVES AND SO THEIR WAY TO
DO THIS THAT ARE NOT OVERLY
BURDENSOME WILL NOT COST
AGENCIES LIKE MONEY. OR AND WILL
NOT PROHIBIT AGENCIES FROM
CONDUCTING THEIR ORDINARY COURSE
OF BUSINESS AGAIN WE SAW THIS
HAPPEN AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL YOU
BOMB ADMINISTRATION OVER FIVE
YEARS WAS STILL ABLE TO ENACT
VERY ROBUST PROTECTIONS FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT WORKERS AND OTHERS.
.
AND SO FOR THOSE REASONS WE
ENCOURAGE YOU TO VOTE ON THE
BILL.
THANK YOU MUCH EMAIL SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL TODAY.
REC TIME OF HAVE A CALIFORNIA MS
PROPERTIES ASSOCIATION I LIKE
THAT THE AUTHOR'S AND AGREEING
WITH WHAT MISTER COOK SAID WE
ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU ANYBODY'S BEGIN
OPPOSITION TODAY.
BUT A CHAIR MEMBERS MICHAEL
YOUNG WITH CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION.
WE'RE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE FOR
SIMILAR REASONS THAT WE WERE
OPPOSED TO THE FARM BILL SO I
WON'T.
REITERATE ISSUES THAT THAT ARE
ALREADY PRESENT IT BUT I WILL.
FOCUS ON THE FACT THAT THE.
YIELDS ARE DOING THIS WORK OUT
WOULD AGREE WITH THE AUTHORS
THAT.
IT'S A REASONABLE.
THEORY IS A REASONABLE NOTION
THAT STATE AGENCIES SHOULD.
REVIEW REGULATIONS TO MAKE SURE
THEY'RE CONSISTENT NOT
DUPLICATIVE AND THAT'S WHY THEY
ALREADY DO IT THAT'S WHY BEFORE
REGULATION GOES INTO PLACE THE
IF THE AGENCY REVIEWS REGULATION
MIXERS CONSISTENT CURRENT LAW.
AND THEY WORK WITH ONLY ABLE TO
MAKE SURE THAT THAT REGULATION
AGAIN IS CONSISTENT WITH THE
PRIORITIES OF THE APA TO MAKE
SURE THAT IT'S CONSISTENT
CURRENT LAW NOT DUPLICATIVE NOW
OVER BURDENSOME.
AND FURTHER WINDOWS REGULATIONS
ARE WHEN WE FIVE REGULATION A
STEP THROUGH CRACKS AND WE BY
REGULATIONS AYE AS YOU GUYS
MENTION SOMETIMES YOU HAVE TO
CONSTITUENTS THAT THIS
PARTICULAR A PARTICULAR
REGULATION IS INCONSISTENT CAR
OFF. THEIR ALREADY MECHANISMS IN
PLACE TO REPEAL THOSE
REGULATIONS YOU CAN ASK AGENCY
YOU CAN AT YOU CAN GO THROUGH
THE OLEO YOU CAN WORK THROUGH
THOSE EXISTING PART YOU CAN GO
TO WORK THROUGH THOSE EXISTING
MECHANISMS TO. REPEAL
REGULATIONS WITH THIS BILL SAYS
IS THAT BY EVERY STATE AGENCY IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WILL
HAVE TO RE REVIEW. EVERY
REGULATION THAT THEY'VE EVER
PASSED.
THAT'S WORK THAT THE ALLELES
ARE DONE THAT'S WHAT THE AGENCY
ARE DESIGNED AND IS TAKING A
RESOURCES FROM THOSE AGENCIES
FROM DOING THEIR CORE MISSION
AND I WILL ALSO LEADS THE READER
WORK JUST STATE THAT.
IN THIS NEW ENVIRONMENT WHERE
YOU HAVE THE REGULATION OR THE
FEDERAL LEVEL IT'S FALL INTO
CALIFORNIA STATE AGENCIES TO
ENFORCE CALIFORNIA PRIORITIES
ARE VALUES SO WHEN YOU SEE SORT
OF THE DISMANTLING OF THE EPA ON
THE FEDERAL LEVEL OR YOU SEE THE
CHANGES ONE. OF THE LABOR AGENCY
ON THE FEDERAL LEVEL OR YOU SEE
THEIR THOUGHTS THAT FACTOR
IMMIGRANTS A FALSE TO
CALIFORNIANS ARE CONSTITUENTS
RELY ONE CALIFORNIA'S THE
AGENCIES TO DO THAT WORK SO WHEN
YOU HAD THE SORT OF. UNNECESSARY
NEW BURDENS YOU PUT ALL AGENCIES
WITHOUT BY THEM NEW RESOURCES
WHEN THERE'S ALREADY A STATE
AGENCY WAS RD DOING GIVE YOU'RE
REALLY DOING A DISSERVICE TO
THOSE AGENCIES JOE HAD LABOR
AGENCY. FOCUSING ALWAYS THAT YOU
DON'T HAVE THE EPA FOCUSING ON
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION
YOU HAD THEM DOING THE WORK OF
THE OLEO AGAIN BUT WHEN THE RT
HAD THE AUTHORITY IN THE
RESOURCE DO THE WORK THIS BILL
IS ASKING THEM TO DO SO FOR
THOSE REASONS WERE POST.
YEAH MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MARKETS
BEGINNING WITH THE CALIFORNIA
NURSES ASSOCIATION AND.
UNDERSTAND THAT A NUMBER OF THE
POINTS TODAY HAVE BEEN.
DEBATED A STATED ON THE PHONE
BILLS WELL SO WILL NECESSARILY
BELABOR THE POINT SO TO SAY THAT
I'M WE TO ALSO RESPECT THE
OFFICE GOALS IN TERMS OF
ENSURING THAT ON THERE IS SOME
REVIEW. OF REGULATIONS AND.
DUPLICATION AND THINGS THAT ARE
SORT OF OUR PRESENT ON IN OUR
STATE'S REGULATIONS BUT ON WE
FEEL THAT EXISTING LAW ALREADY
SUFFICIENTLY ADDRESSES THE
ISSUE.
OF THE OFFICE OF ADMINISTRATIVE
LAW HAS A PROCESS TO REVIEW
REGULATIONS ENSURING THAT THEY
MEET THE ON REQUIREMENTS OF THE
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCEDURE ACT.
THEY LOOK AT ON THE NUMBER OF
THINGS INCLUDING NECESSITY
AUTHORITY CLARITY CONSISTENCY
REFERENCE AND A LASTLY NON
DUPLICATION.
AND THE O. L. ALSO AS A POWER
SAYS TO CONDUCT PRIORITY REVIEW
REGULATIONS THAT FILLS DOES NOT
MEET THE STANDARDS OF THE
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCEDURES ACT.
AMON ADDITION TO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC HAVE ANY ABILITY TO
PETITION. AND ALMOST OF OTHER
THINGS AND SO AGAIN WHILE WE
APPRECIATE THE GOALS OF THE
AUTHOR'S.
WE ULTIMATELY FEELS AS THOUGH
IT DIVERTS RESOURCES AWAY FROM
IMPORTANT DUTIES RELATING TO
WORKER AND FAMILY SAFETY IN
CALIFORNIA AND FOR THOSE REASONS
WE HAVE TO OPPOSE. THANK YOU
WANT BUT. THE LAST WITNESS BRIEF
PLACE.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS TIM CAMERA
BE HAVE SEIU LOCAL ONE THOUSAND
REPRESENTING THE STATE WORKERS
WITH CAN CALIFORNIA.
I THINK MY BROTHER ELOQUENTLY
SENATE ALREADY SO I WILL JUST
SAY THAT WE TO RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE.
I THINK VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE
BEGIN OPPOSITION.
MATT BROUGHT HERE ON BEHALF THE
TEAMSTERS LONGSHOREMEN UNITE
HERE PATH EIGHTY YOU YOU W. A
AND I'LL RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION
THAT YOU.
VERY MUCH OKAY.
QUESTIONS CONTRA COMMITTEE.
I WILL SAY THAT I THINK THIS IS
MUCH MORE NARROWLY TAILORED THEN
WE THE OTHER BILL THAT WE SPOKE
ABOUT TODAY AND AND I THINK
BEFORE. AS A AS A SOCIAL
PROFESSIONAL BEFORE WE EVER TRY
TO INTERVENE WITH ANYBODY WE DO
A FULL ASSESSMENT FIRST ARE YOU
CAN'T TREAT SOMETHING UNTIL YOU
KNOW WHAT YOU'RE DEALING WITH.
AND I THINK THERE ARE RESOURCES
THAT EVERY AGENCY CAN USE THAT
WORK THAT HAS ALREADY BEEN GOING
ON GOING TO BE ABLE TO COMPILE.
SOMETHING LIKE THIS.
AND AGAIN I SUBMITTED UP.
PROPOSAL MISTER COOLEY LAST
YEAR YEAR BEFORE LAST ABOUT
MAKING THIS COMMITTEE A LITTLE
BIT MORE BEEFY ON ITS ABILITY TO
DO OVERSIGHT. AND ACCOUNTABILITY
AND I HOPE THAT WE CAN CONTINUE
THAT CONVERSATION AS WE CONTINUE
THE CONVERSATION ABOUT LOOKING
AT ALL THE RICH BUT REGULATIONS.
OKAY ANY OTHER MEMBERS WANT TO
SPEAK MISTER MISTER CLEAREST CAO
RESPECT TO POSITIONS OF THE OF
THE OPPOSITION YOU KNOW YOU'RE
TALKING TO A MEMBER HERE THAT
VIRTUALLY EVERY YEAR OF IN THE
LEGISLATURE OF A HUNDRED PERCENT
VOTING RECORD. WITH WITH LABOR
SO IT IS ABSOLUTELY NOT MY
INTENTION ANY WAY SHAPE OR FORM
TO PUT OUR LABOR. UNIONS IN
CALIFORNIA ANY TYPE ABOUT
POSITION BY DOING THIS OPERAS AT
THE SAME TIME I THINK WHAT HAS
TO BE RECOGNIZED IS THAT. YOU
KNOW YOU COULD HAVE ANY AGENCY
REGULATION THAT GETS DEVELOP
BEALL REVIEWED ARE REVIEWED AYE
AND POTENTIALLY AUGMENTED BUT
THE REALITY IS IS THAT. YOU KNOW
DURING A TIME OF TERM LIMITS I'M
SURE THERE WERE A LOT OF
POLITICAL REASONS WHY CERTAIN
BILLS MAY HAVE PASSED. AT AND IF
IT'S SOMETHING AS PASSED BY LAW
YOU CAN'T JUST ELIMINATED IT IN
LAW CODIFIED BY LAW PASSED BY
THE LEGISLATURE AND SIGNED BY
THE GOVERNOR. AND SO.
THAT'S NOT JUST EASILY
DISPENSED WITH AND SO I I DON'T
THINK IT'S A ARE UNFAIR AND AND
AND TOO MUCH OF A BURDEN.
TO TAKE THE TIME TO REVIEW ALL
THE STATE REGULATIONS THAT WE
HAVE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE I. THEY ARE OUT OF DATE
DUPLICATIVE NO LONGER WRAPPED
REBEL RELEVANT.
REGULATIONS THAT WE'RE LOOKING
FOR AND AGAIN THIS STUDY MAY
TURN UP SAYING THAT THERE ARE
NONE AND I'M FINE WITH THAT BUT
I THINK IS REALLY IMPORTANT AND
OUR OVERSIGHT CAPACITY WHICH.
ARE LEGISLATIVE BODY ESPECIALLY
NOW BEING OF TWELVE YEARS HAVE
TRIED TO FOCUS MORE TIME AND
ATTENTION ON.
THAT WE TAKE THE TIME TO TAKE
THAT THAT THAT REGULATORY
OVERSIGHT.
IT'S IT'S PART OF OUR JOBS PART
OF OUR DUTY I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE WOULD DEFERRED ANY
OTHER COME TO MY.
JOINT AUTHORED.
WELL I THINK THE OUT DATED
COMPONENTS MOST IMPORTANT ONE
BECAUSE AS WE KNOW THE WORLD
CHANGES.
ON A DAILY WEEKLY MONTHLY YEARLY
BASIS.
AS FOR REGULATION DRAFTED A
POINT IN TIME WHICH MAKES SENSE.
DON'T KEEP UP WITH CHANGES IN
THE OUTSIDE WORLD.
AND SO THIS ELEMENT OF LOOKING
FOR ANY ASPECT OF OUTDATED NESS.
IS NOT SOMETHING THAT THE APA
SYSTEM IS REALLY SET UP A FUND
INTO TO CONFRONT.
THERE DOOR TRYING TO ADOPT
TIMELY REGULATIONS.
BUT CIRCUMSTANCES CHANGE AND
THERE HAVE BEEN SUCH
REVOLUTIONS.
IN THE WAY BUSINESS IS
CONDUCTED.
AS WE ALL WELL KNOW SO I THINK
THAT'S A.
THE.
OPPOSITION IS NOT RESPONSIVE THE
OUTDATED ASPECT AND AGAIN I
THINK AS A ELECTED OFFICIALS IT
IS. OUR. OUR CHALLENGE IN OUR
AREA.
TO ESTABLISH A PARTICIPATORY
DEMOCRACY WORKS AND SHOULD BE
RESPECTED.
AND THAT MEANS WE NEED TO BE
OPEN TO.
TO.
EXAMINE OUR CITY GOVERNMENT
WORKS
I THINK THIS ALLIANCE WITH THE
ANGELS
ON ARE SWORN OBLIGATION THE
CONSTITUTION.
WITH THE ANGELS.
NPR ALRIGHT TAKE THAT AS A CLOSE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DUE PATH AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS THAT ABOUT THE
STATEMENT THAT A MONTH AS A MAN
I'VE PATTERSON. BURKE.
BURKE I FRAZIER.
FRASER YEAH AS LACKEY.
LACKEY YES MEDINA.
MEDINA NOT VOTING QUIRK SILVA.
HURT HERSELF BUT YES I.
PAYNE THANK YOU HAVE A BILL AS
OUT. GO WITH GOD UP MS BURKE.
HELLO.
STILL MORNING GOOD MORNING GOOD
MORNING.
.
THANK YOU A MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I KNOW WE SAY THIS A LOT
OF US AT THE BEGINNING OF ALL OF
US BECAUSE I WON I THINK YOU AND
YOUR STAFF FOR YOUR WORK BUT I
REALLY DO MEAN THANK YOU. THEIR
STAFF AND YOU FOR THE WORK ON
THIS BILL AND STARTING JANUARY
FIRST TWO THOUSAND TWENTY TWO
FOR VEHICLES OVER NINETEEN
THOUSAND POUNDS. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY FIVE OH SIX WILL REQUIRE
DIGEST MAKE FIFTEEN PERCENT OF
THE NEW VEHICLE PURCHASE RUN ON
RENEWABLE GAS.
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN AT THE
FOREFRONT OF CREATING POLICY TO
COMBAT OR IMPACT ON CLIMATE
CHANGE AND APPROVING IMPROVING
AIR QUALITY IT'S CRITICAL YOU
TRUST BOTH GHG EMISSIONS AND
CRITERIA POLLUTANTS WHICH
RESULTS IN PULMONARY AND
CARDIOVASCULAR DISEASE FOR
CALIFORNIANS IN AREAS WITH POOR
AIR QUALITY.
MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES
ARE THE PRIMARY CONTRIBUTORS TO
CRITERIA POLLUTANTS PASSED IN
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN S. B.
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE. AMONG
OTHER GOALS THAT TARGETS FOR THE
REDUCTION OF METHANE EMISSIONS
FROM TERRY'S BY USING THOSE
METHANE EMISSIONS TO PRODUCE
RENEWABLE GAS.
WITH ME HERE.
WITH ME HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THE HUT IS HER DIET
YOUNG ON BEHALF OF THE CALTRAIN
AFTER GAS VEHICLE COLLISION OF
MICHAEL BOOK OR ON BEHALF THE
AGRICULTURE AND YOU CONSUMER
ASSOCIATION.
MUCH OF THANK YOU. BURKE THANK
YOU CHAIR MEMBERS I MY NAME IS
JOSIAH YOUNG ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA NATURAL GAS VEHICLE
ASSOCIATION OF THIS IS AN
ASSOCIATION OF NATURAL GAS
VEHICLE AND ENGINE MANUFACTURERS
UTILITIES FUEL PROVIDERS AND
OPERATORS ACROSS THE STATE. WERE
PLEASED TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
THAT WILL CLEAN UP THE STATE
HEAVY DUTY TRUCKING FLEET.
I ALSO WANT TO MENTION THAT THE
RENEWABLE NATURAL GAS COALITION
ASKED THAT WE LINE THEM WITH OUR
COMMENTS. OF THIS EXPANSION ON
THE ZEV PROCUREMENT MANDATE IN
LAST YEAR'S AB SEVEN THIRTY NINE
WHICH WAS HARD BY THIS
COMMITTEE.
I GUESS THE CLEANEST AVAILABLE
TRUCKS ON THE ROAD SOONER AND
RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF
BIOFUELS PARTICULARLY RENEWABLE
NATURAL GAS AS A COMPONENT OF A
CLEAN LOW CARBON ALTERNATIVE
FUEL PORTFOLIO IN CALIFORNIA. OF
THE BILL ALSO WAS A VEHICLE TO
FULFILL THE CRITERIA AIR
POLLUTANT DUCKS IN GOALS IN S.
B. THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE. AS
MENTIONED BY THE AUTHOR AND ONE
OF THE HIGHEST AND BEST USE IS
OF THOSE CAPTURED EMISSIONS ARE
AS A TRANSPORTATION FUEL. IN THE
FORM OF RENEWABLE NATURAL GAS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I'LL
I'LL BE VERY BRIEF THE STATE'S
INVESTING TWO HUNDRED AND SIXTY
MILLION DOLLARS OF G. JEREH
FUNDING. IN DERRY METHANE
REDUCTION EFFORTS THE INDUSTRY'S
MATCHING THAT WITH THREE
QUARTERS OF A BILLION DOLLARS.
SO WE'VE GOT ABOUT A BILLION
DOLLAR INVESTMENT MOST OF THESE
PROJECTS ARE MAKING
TRANSPORTATION FEEL IT WILL BE
VERY SOON. AND WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE WE HAVE MARKETS THIS BILL
ENSURES WE HAVE MARKETS FOR THAT
BUT NOTHING. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
I A RYAN KENNY.
WITH CLEAN ENERGY IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK.
YOU.
EVERY STREET IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL TODAY.
THE COMMISSION COULD MISTER
BRAZIER THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR SO
AS THE CHAIRMAN OF THE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE WE'VE
WORKED ON THIS ISSUE WITH THE.
CALTRANS IS THAT THEY'RE PRETTY
MUCH THE BUYERS OF THE NINETEEN
THOUSAND POUNDS AND OVER WE'VE
DONE BEST VALUE BILLS WITH
CALTRANS TO BE ABLE TO.
GET THE MOST EFFICIENT USAGE OF
THE TAXPAYER'S MONEY THIS IS THE
BRIDGE.
TO CLEAN ENERGY.
AS TECHNOLOGY AND FULL OF.
ROLLS OUT AND.
AND AGAIN WE NEED TO EMBRACE
THESE OTHER PROPERTIES OF. OF
HOW WE GET OF THE VALUE TO THE
PEOPLE AND ALSO WOULD. HAVE
CLEAN AIR AND SO I'M NOT REALLY.
.
LOOK FORWARD TO THAT.
PERCENTAGE GROWING.
BUT THIS IS A GREAT START.
AND.
LOOKING FORWARD TO THE SUCCESS
THAT YOU HAVE WITH THIS BILL OF.
SOME A MEMBER BURKE THINK YOU.
NO SPEAKING TODAY QUESTIONS.
OF YEAH AND.
AND I I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO THANK
THE STEPHENS WHAT WE ALL REALLY
DUG IN AND WORKED VERY HARD ON
THIS TO MAKE.
THE REALITY OF CREATING THOSE
MARKETS AND ALSO REALIZING THAT
THE STATE HAS ALREADY INVESTED
IN AND AND OTHER. PASSED THAT WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THEY GET THEIR
LIFETIME YOU SELDOM SO WE SAVE
TAXPAYER DOLLARS AT THE SAME
TIME CONTINUE TO SET THE BAR FOR
WORK SO. I THINK WE BECAME TO
ABOUT A WONDERFUL PLACE WITH THE
ANGELS I I WOULD SAY. THAT IF
YOU'D LIKE TO CLOSE MISS BURKE.
YEAH.
I THINK WE'LL LEAVE IT AT THAT.
OKAY AS FAVORITE PERSON I'VE
EVER.
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED
CORRECT
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS THEM BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS THAT I'M NOT THE
STATEMENT. SOMEONE THIS EGGMAN
AYE PATTERSON.
BURKE.
BURKE AYE FRAZIER FRAZIER I'D
LACKEY LACKEY AYE MEDINA MEDINA
AND QUIRK SILVA.
KIRK SILVA AYE.
REVENGE OF BILLS OUT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
FEDERATION FOR SIX SEVEN ONE.
HARM.
SELECT.
BUT. WHICH ONE.
THERE'S NO OTHER.
YEAH.
OKAY BUT WE HAVE SOME I THINK.
WE I'M AND OF.
WE'RE TO LIFT THE CALL OF WE ARE
ALSO MINISTER OF HAVE MS BURKE
ADD ON TO SOMETHING SO SHE WAS
SO CHOOSE AND THIS MISTER
PATTERSON WANT TO COME BACK OUT
ONTO.
IT IT.
TWENTY SINCE EVERYONE LIKE.
OKAY YEAH.
YEAH. YEAH.
YEAH I WAS IT DOESN'T TAKE ONE
HUNDRED.
THE. CONSENT CALENDAR BURKE.
BURKE I.
AB TWENTY THREE NINETY SIX
BIGELOW BURKE BURKE AYE.
A BEAT TWENTY SIX SEVENTY ONE
FONG BURKE.
BURKE I.
PHILIP.
FOR.
FOR AB TWENTY SIX SEVENTY ONE
FONG QUIRK SO. IS AND NOT VOTING
TWO.
I.
BUT SO MR FUNG'S BILLS ALSO OUT.
I AB 27-29 BURKE.
BURKE I.
FOR AB TWENTY NINE SEVENTY ONE
CALDERON PATTERSON.
PATTERSON I.
AB TWENTY SEVEN FORTY NINE BONTA
PATTERSON.
PATTERSON I.
AB TWENTY EIGHTY SEVEN A WALDRON
PATTERSON. PATTERSON AYE.
AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY ONE WEBER
PATTERSON.
PATTERSON NO.
AND.
AB TWENTY FIVE ALL SIX THE BURKE
PATTERSON PATTERSON AYE.
DURING THIS MEETING